hey it is 5:00 a.m. and we are thirty
people away from in a million I'm doing
a big giveaway today let's see who's
we're gonna give away I'm giving away a
one-on-one coaching session with me I'm
giving away 50 copies of my book and I'm
giving away 50 packs of my lunch for
Heroes trading cards it'll go to the
people on the live stream and the people
watching afterwards if you are leaving
comments afterwards stay tuned I don't
know how many I'm giving away live by
how many giving away to the people
afterwards but I'll figure it out I just
I am waking up guys I like got out of
bed my wife Nina rushed in and said
you're gonna hit a million soon you
gotta come in so if I'm not exactly a
hundred percent on the ball at the
moment hopefully you guys will be okay
alright I'm ready to go here's what
we're gonna do we're gonna do some
giveaways my case here's gonna happen
when we cross a million are you
something that I did at 500 thousand
Thank You Bernard Bernard for the
subscription we take the chats the chats
blow it up let me explain the rules let
me explain the rules okay when we cross
a million I'm gonna type believe into
the check the first person the hits
believe that rights believe with the
hashtag I'm gonna type hashtag believe
when we cross a million and the first
person to do hashtag believe right after
me it's the one right after me that
person wins a one-on-one coaching
session with me hangout Skype zoom we'll
figure it out what are you laughing we
had a million I type it the first one
after me so it's easy to see okay from
there we're gonna do some Q&A I want to
answer your questions I want to
celebrate with you guys it's gonna be
fun and whoever's questions we end up
picking is gonna get a free
my book autographs I'm gonna mail it to
you I've got a wall of books here where
does it give out
oh she turn on the light hey can we turn
the way here we got a little more
brightness that's that I need that oh
sorry yeah I just got up I just go up
okay and then I mostly only give up oxic
cards the ones that we don't give away
in the live stream it's gonna be in the
comments so after the video goes live in
the comments it's gonna show I'm going
to leave something at the top to say how
many prizes is still available and then
so if we have like 50 prizes still
available the first 50 comments we'll
get those prizes okay that's a plan now
someone on my team are you laughing okay
GRI is on my team suggested we do a
choose your own adventure game so I'm
going to take two questions from the
live chat I'm gonna put them up against
each other
a or B you guys will vote on who I'm
gonna do and whoever I pick gets a copy
of the book I need to keep this I need
to keep track of how many I'm giving
away here we're 30 away yeah so where
you got home before we give away the
stuff I don't know what you guys are
from - I am in California Alexandra's up
this is awesome were you guys were you
guys I thought it'd be hidden all the
overseas people but you guys are up
early
you guys are up with me Portugal Sanford
San Francisco you guys haven't gone to
bed yet India South Africa Lebanon New
York City okay
it's just flying in I can't even keep up
I can't even keep up that's awesome guys
I love you guys so much all over the
world I love it Paris Nigeria Pakistan
Chicago what else London Sri Lanka India
Texas
Zeno's here I already say now I saw you
fly by miss what you said Louisiana
Vietnam okay okay here's gonna do I want
to answer questions I want to be a
resource for you guys I want to thank
you so much for all your support over
the years what your she's cool
I need I need water okay so what I want
to do is you guys have questions for
your business something I can help you
out with while I'm here
I want to pull two questions from the
chat and then you guys will vote on them
question any or question be whoever I
whoever you guys pick gets a free copy
of the book signed I'm gonna mail it to
you my expense and we got we got fifty
books to give away and 50 packs of the
entrepreneur let me show you the cards
the cards that are up there are this the
entrepreneur trading cards it's like a
whole bunch of these different
entrepreneurs have put together years
ago
okay so questions what do you guys got
let's see I saw something up there let
me I'm gonna I'm gonna just a chat okay
what's up next for you and your channel
okay okay
question a is what's up next for you and
your channel
what's question B what you guys got
question a oh my god the Chad's out of
control who asked that question what's
up next can I find it mmm with a more
vim mmm okay next
give me another question Mira Bedi I'm
going with you right here okay B Mira
how to grow business with a low budget
Mira
okay guys question a what's up next for
me and my youtube channel question B how
to grow business with a low budget vote
give me your vote let me see a or be a
what's up next with Ewing in YouTube
channel B how to grow business the low
budget okay vote vote vote you guys are
gonna tell me who's gonna get the book
Nina I pick what is it a lot of bees you
guys no one no it's next with my channel
I look up at 5:00 a.m. for this ok it
looks like you're going be be ok first
book goes to Mira I love it Mira I need
to set out the instructions right I mean
it's a Mira email my assistant Sandra at
Evan karmic
komm we'll figure this out we'll get the
book to you one book go back and knock
this over book goes to Mary
okay well let's answer the question Mira
how to grow business the low budget my
brain is my brain is melting right now
what's the best second vice and give you
on this so a couple things first off
start with the service based business
when you start with product base it cost
you more right so you're off spending
money on equipment on tools like
inventory I hate that I hate spending
money telling making money and so I
always try to start a business that is
service based because just your time and
at the beginning you have more time than
you do have money so you're off trying
to meet people trying to make
connections trying to get going and you
can have a long term roadmap to be able
to build a product but start with a
service the other thing it does besides
saving you money is it gets you close to
your customers so when you're doing a
service based business you're connecting
one-on-one with people you're
understanding what's wrong in their
business what their pain points are and
then it's a lot easier to then sell them
a product cuz you already have some cash
show coming in and you have a connection
to customers who can already buy it from
you
second thing is I would look at how can
I transition from my job to start them
in business so can you learn from your
job right now
right so if you're in a job where you're
not learning it's gonna be a big mistake
like you don't want to have a job just
to make money you have a job to learn
the industry to get experienced to learn
the ropes and so if I'm if I'm in a job
where I'm not learning I'm not making
connections I'm leaving that job to go
do another job where I can learn to make
connections I've been looking at how can
I transition from my job to a business
where one I'm either selling back to my
company so I'm a contractor now to the
company that I'm working for or I'm
looking at using one of the connections
that I make inside my business to go
like inside my job to go start my
company
so like a customer that I'm already
working with and so that when you start
your business you already have a
customer in hand and third thing I'd
recommend is what I did in my business
my first business when I was struggling
and
shocking is partnerships the fastest way
to grow one of the fastest ways that
grows look at somebody who already has
your target market and find a way to
partner up with them are we losing
subscribers we've lost subscribers since
we started yeah what is up guys you just
want to see your name show up on the
side as I was happening
Rupesh come on depeche yeah I've been
looking at I'd be looking at I'd be
looking at who is already selling to my
target audience and how can I make some
kind of partnership with them so that
they have an incentive to want to sell
my product that's what Bill Gates did
with Microsoft he built it by partnering
up with all sorts of different companies
so that when you bought a computer it
had Microsoft software on it what's the
equivalent in your business when
somebody buys X then they're also gonna
want to buy your thing go partner up
with all the people that sell X and
partners them and give them equity
partner means just find a way to work
together
it could be giving them a commission it
could be giving them exposure it could
be something else every every deal you
make is different and so I highly
recommend doing that good Mira thanks
for the question and congrats you got
the first book let's give away another
book I need water I miss a bill in the
house okay Christina in the house I love
it hey my team is here Christina
Christina I cancelled today's interested
by the way because they're doing this
live stream so it's also my wife and
eyes are my wife and eyes it's our
month-aversary it's our month-aversary
oh she wants to come in for that she
wants to come in for that there she is
there's the wife I want to thank my team
before I get to the next question I got
my wife who always a super supportive
and woke me up for this why were you
even awake
and then I saw a nice i sat there - Nina
came woke me up I love it
she's so special this doesn't happen
without Nina guys so give me some props
Cristina did my video editor four years
Cristina years and she's in the live
chat so you can give her give her some
some extra love there her husband Sam
joined the team
Nina's give enough to Cristina her
husband Sam joined the team a couple
years ago you're gonna have to go home
and I don't remember but her and Sam or
that are the one-two punch and do most
of the videos in the channel the
Brotherhood of Ivan and Luca who take
care of the research on the team for all
the videos as well as all the comments
responding Sandra my personal assistant
who will be sending out all the books to
you guys Sam Sam said three years ago
man it's been a long time Wow time just
flies sorry Sam okay what who else who
else you need to think of course J Rhys
I talked about Darius at the beginning
who helped with the idea that for this
for the game the a/b split and then
Jason helps me film the videos myself
thank you to myself for showing up and
making three videos a day Nina you got
to get in here if you're gonna comment
yeah people to hear your voice but they
can't see you okay thank you guys and
thank you guys the audience for showing
up and doing you know being with me all
the time
Miha villains a new in the house my
administrators in the live chat who keep
it clean and friendly I love it you guys
are the best okay let's get to another
question
okay so here's something to questions
I'm gonna pick two and then you guys are
gonna vote on which one I'm gonna answer
okay we ready to give one buck away to
Meera let's see what's next okay here we
go here we go here we go Oh Joanne tag
me
yes I love this tag tag me I see the
question can I take this one here
hey it's from Joanne what did you
thought around the phrase customers I
was right I saw another one that's
another tag where was it
Shawn B who is my go-to motivator okay
guys time to vote
time to vote hey what's your thought on
the phrase customer's always right
B who is your go-to motivator vote a
what is your thought around the phrase
customer's always right
B who is my go-to motivator okay vote
vote vote put a or B in the comments
Nina you might need a pick Nina it's
tight tight men come on pick pick Nina
what do you got a what's your thought on
the French customers always right that
be who is your go-to motivator your eyes
are hurting
don't make my wife's eyes hurt
what do you want Nina include one where
we're going okay we're both two winners
Joanne and Sean both get a signed book
email Sandra at Evan Carmichael calm
include this clip or a link to it or the
video whatever I have your names here
too and all right we've just given away
three books already out of fifty I love
it okay
Joanne so let's answer them we got
answer these now you know what are your
thoughts on the customer's always right
you should have seen that reaction that
was great Nina come on you gotta give in
you gotta get on there well yes we got
29 subscribers away from hitting a
million so customer's always right for
me
I think it depends on on bringing on the
right customer I don't I don't believe
the customer's always right
I've dealt with some customers that were
wrong and it just just depends on it's
not that they're wrong and you're right
it's whether just just a misalignment of
values I think this is why it's really
important to find your
right I've been on this path for a long
time but having self-awareness figuring
out your values because when you have a
misalignment of values you're both going
to feel you're right and you just come
from different spots now I would say I
believe that customer service is really
really important
well we just jumped up like a lot we got
we got 20 more hours 18 18 more look at
that spike that just happened yeah hey
you guys sixteen more okay we'll keep
going customer's always right
I believe customer service is really
important I believe when over deliver
like crazy I believe in word-of-mouth
and that comes from when you just
provide such an amazing service to your
customers that they want to spread the
word that they want to tell people about
it that they want to keep passing on the
message I think you you want to give way
way way way way more than what is
expected you want to love them first and
they will love you back and that's the
secret to growth for a lot of
entrepreneurs we're not out taking Super
Bowl commercials right we can't take
those big ad budget campaigns out and
now we just tanked what happened we just
lost a bunch of people so the way that
we Wayne is off of the service that
amazing customer service so I think
that's really really important when I
looked at Toronto dents also the
business I acquired last year that's one
of the things we we focus on it's one
thought leadership for Alex who helps me
run it and to just providing an
outstanding experience we want the
in-class experience to be amazing we
want the email experience to be amazing
working a new signup process with
medival who's in the chat we want that
experience to be amazing and so you want
the customer experience to be amazing
with that being said sometimes our
customers that just don't fit what
you're trying to do as an example I've
had brains that I've worked with one
brand of reticular they told me the deal
I didn't I didn't like the deal I didn't
they just felt too transactional like
for when I come on and talk about a
brand with you guys it's one because
I've used them and I like them when I'm
a customer like I don't recommend stuff
to you that I don't use myself and I'm
not
Phaneuf and to that when they're coming
on they're trying to provide value and
not just cell where a lot of brands
don't come with that mindset they come
in wanting to sell like oh you have a
lot of entrepreneurs how about how about
you go on and talk about our insurance
product or our credit card and get
people to sign up it's like that's not
that's not what I do
you know like you paid zero attention to
my channel I don't come on and just
pitch products we need to provide value
somehow to the entrepreneurs and so I
was asked to do a deal
and it was I only accepted it because of
a mutual connection it was a an agency I
had worked with before
and I said please help us out with this
one please help us out so I said okay
and we signed a a two two or three part
deal and after the first video that I
made with them we cancelled it because
what they wanted and what I could give
them we just have a different value
alignment I'm sure some other some other
influencer could have given what they
wanted if he's gone and pitch their
product it's just not what I do
and so I think when you have that really
clear values misalignment then then then
they're not right and this again not the
fact that they're right and you're wrong
you just have a misalignment but but
again you want to provide outstanding
customer service it's really crucial for
you guys to get off 15 more or 14 more
we're getting closer you know we're
getting close limas here 13 more okay
let's Hanson next question Shawn was who
is my go-to motivator so the easiest
answer is my own channel I love my
channel not not to watch me but to watch
the content that that I'm putting out so
all the different people that I'm
profile on my channel I made the channel
you know what keeps me going is this
idea that it's a daily channel there's
daily content that no matter what time
you're coming there's a new video out
there with somebody who has
extraordinary ideas and great motivation
to help you grow to help you become
better it's around not just
entrepreneurship but around
success and I think that's really really
important if I had to pick an individual
who was my individual go-to motivator my
individual go-to motivator I would
probably pick so if I had to pick like
all-time I like young Les Brown why
don't you answer for me they mean that
okay if you're gonna talk you have to
come on camera you gotta you gotta stick
your head in there
young Les Brown I love young Les Brown
that guy's a motivator but he doesn't
produce enough content right like first
of all he's not young anymore
and second of all there's not that much
like a lot of people that might be go to
don't have a ton of content out there so
young that's brown I love Tony Robbins
again Tony doesn't produce enough
content regularly on YouTube channels to
be able to say like every day I'm gonna
watch something so from the guys who do
go daily I think Gary Vaynerchuk is
probably the best every day he's got new
videos every day is that new content
we're often helping mark and promote the
work that he's doing we've been in a
race to hit 2 million my thinking I get
there first what's let's see what's Gary
Vee what's Gary Viet let's go let's go
do a quick check check it off mine for a
second let's go check with Gary Vee is
that Gary Vee is at nine seventy nine
seventy Gary Gary you know it wasn't
tight rates it was a tight race but he
slacked off in the summer well he
slacked off a bit in the summer so but
it's anyway we're both adding lots of
value to the entren community and I'm
super happy that there's so much great
content that is being added okay we gave
away three books guys again the prizes
this week we're getting close to million
I'll stay on afterwards had some more
questions cuz I want to help you in some
water let me talk about the prizes out
the prizes once we hit a million I'm
going to type hashtag believe into the
chat let me load up my chat so I got
that the first person the type
Tagg believe after me gets a free
one-on-one coaching session with me
Skype zoom hangouts whatever we'll
figure it out
apart from that I'm giving away 50
copies of my book signed mailed to your
house and 50 entrepreneur trading card
packs we've already given away three
bucks we're gonna give me some our books
on the stream we're gonna give away some
more and alive in the comments
afterwards I bought me some water thank
you is amazing
thank you my wife bought me water so a
hundred and one prizes coaching session
with me is a grand prize you know I'm
gonna I'm gonna throw in I'm gonna throw
in I should talk to Lily shows talk to
Lily
Lily's not here Lily are you in the chat
Lily if you're gonna chat let me know
I'm thinking about throwing in some Lily
sessions on top for the grand prize okay
we've given away three books let's go
next question give me up questions guys
tag me give me a question we got we got
zeroes supremacy okay I'm gonna copy
this in question a is how should one
recruit his team for his business okay
okay and and here we go oh I read our
our retry a Reacher okay question B I
like it what should be the motivation
after several failures okay question a
go vote guys time to vote question a how
should one recruit his team for his
business question B what should be the
motivation after several failures vote a
or b a how should one recruit his team
for his business B what should be the
motivation after several failures go a
or be a or b what do you want Nina pick
what do you got pick Nina see more B's
we're going B Nina be a Reacher gets a
free box sign we're gonna mail it off to
you thank you for the great question
alright email my assistants and you're
at Evan Carmichael calm and we'll get
the signed book off to you okay
I reach a let's answer this question
what should be the motivation after
several failures so listen first off
well I think we need to change a
perspective around failure I think
people have this mistaken notion that
they need to succeed at everything and
if you succeed then you suck you know
failure is expected you you not that you
seek out failure and you like you're
just looking to fail all the time but
the people who succeed the most are the
ones who fail the most across everything
across athletics across entrepreneurship
across everything the people who succeed
the most of the ones who fail the most
so you need to fail more you need to
fail more more fail more if you're
taking more shots at it and the more you
fail the better you're gonna get and so
one not taking it as a reflection of
your identity so that because I failed
at this product this project that means
I suck no it just means that it didn't
work out and the next time you're gonna
do it better and so what we look up to
whoever the person is that you think is
a genius that you look up to look at
their store and see how many times they
fail and you'll see that it was a lot so
it's okay
I look at my channel to see you guys are
watching your frames obviously we've
launched so many new series that don't
work that don't go anywhere and then
every now and then we have a breakout
you know if you look at the top ten is
maybe the most iconic series on my
channel that started off as a one-off
video and you guys liked it and then I
thought huh okay I can do this once a
week once a week it set it off once a
week and then twice a weekend in five
times a week we built it up but along
that path there was a lot of a lot of
churn a lot of other videos a lot of
other series that are gone I don't even
remember what they are I don't even
think about them anymore the ones that
didn't make it and I loved all of them
we put lots of love and energy into all
of them but they're gone because you
guys didn't like them and so we keep the
ones at work and we ditch the ones that
don't it's normal its failure is gonna
be absolutely part of the process so
that's one it's just a mindset to the
thing that I try to keep in mind is the
why like why am I doing this what am I
trying to accomplish what's what's the
mission right give me give me something
powerful to wake up to every day so for
me
you know I want to solve the world's
biggest problem untapped human potential
it's what I wake up every day to try to
do I look at I look at I go look on
homepage every morning you know as part
of my morning routine I open up a whole
bunch of different tabs things that I
need to check in on daily every morning
things like I have to fill up my form of
how much away and how much I ate
yesterday new sights a whole bunch of
things and one of them is my own site
because I want to be inspired every day
and so I load that up and reminded
here's the big problem that I'm trying
to solve here's what I'm trying to go
after and so it's a question I get asked
a lot of how do I know when to quit or
how do I know if I should quit or how do
I know how to keep going and keep going
when you love it if you love it then you
have to keep going let me close this you
see the live chat if you love it you
have to keep going that's when you know
if you lost a love even if you're having
some success that's when you need to
bail that's what you need to either just
quit the business or try to sell it and
try to recoup whatever you can from I
try to get the highest price possible
for it and move on once you've lost a
passion for the business you need to
move on if you never had the passion for
the business and you just started it
because you thought it'd be some hot
opportunity because your cousin told you
this is great forget that move on
immediately but when you love doing what
you're doing you have to find a way to
keep going
that's it like it's a heart test it's
not a brain test you're not you're not
thinking your way through this you're
feeling your way through it
how do you know when you fall in love
it's a heart test that's not a brain
test okay Nina Nina on paper you know
she's very short maybe it's a hard test
it's always a hard test right and so if
you look at if you look at my business
when I first started I had three people
show up to an event that I was doing
three people to a free event that's how
I started this entrepreneurship helping
path I did this event with the YMCA and
three people
showed up now logically practically that
doesn't make sense that it would ever be
a business right if you can only get
three people to a free thing how would
you ever get a business out of this to
get paid to do it and so that's that's
often the case for a lot of successful
entrepreneurs if you look at the early
days of their business it wouldn't make
sense to keep going just logically just
failing and struggling over and over and
over again I'm not getting any results
but they just loved it they loved doing
it so much that they had to keep going I
would keep going helping entrepreneurs
helping you guys maybe not this format
it might be something else but I would
keep doing it even if I never made money
because it fills up my soul because I
love it because it makes me feel
complete you know and so I may not be
able to do it full-time
I may not be able to have a team so my
impact would be a lot smaller but I
would have to find a way to keep going
because I loved it so much and if you
find that thing that you love so much
you have to keep going then quitting is
not an option you just you just keep
going you have to because you love it so
much and so I encourage you to find that
thing and if you have found that thing
then surround yourself with those
resources those ideas those those videos
or books that get you excited that make
you want to keep going that teach you
the stories of successful people who
have failed and have kept going because
it'll make all the difference in the
world we've got nine people left to hit
a million we are close we mean as I say
that who are you guys on subscribing
trolls the eight people we are getting
close okay how many books have we given
away I should keep track of this right
so I don't I don't over over over
promise and under deliver we're giving
away four books me right Joe and Shawn
and our retry retry to get that right
okay let's give away another book let's
give away some more books okay you guys
on the drill two questions we're gonna
pick the winner and we keep going let's
go what do we got I'm going with Tanish
here taneish
we get in contact with people whom I
admire okay that's a good one and then
10 10 mais how do I choose your career
if you have many interests okay let's go
hey how do you get in contact with
people who you admire B how do you
choose your career if you have many
interests a or be a or b hey how'd it
get in contact with people who you
admire B how to choose your career if
you have many interests Nina hey hey for
sure hey winner tummy SHhhh
tummy she gets a free copy of my book
sign sent to your house email my
assistants and you're at Evan Carmichael
calm and we will get that off to you
Sandra's gonna be really busy I haven't
told her that this is happening by the
way we love you Sandra thank you for all
the love okay Oh we're four people away
- from biddings and they were five the
trolls the unsubscribing trolls
okay oh we're three people okay guys
we're getting close okay I can answer
this question with Tanish but we're
getting close again the grand prize
winner
once we cross a million I'm going to
type believe into the check hashtag
believe into the chat and the first
person right after me who hates hashtag
believe who types that in they get the
coaching session with me whatever you
want to ask me I'm gonna help you with
your business one-on-one and maybe we'll
throw in some I want to throw in five
bonus coaching sessions follow-up
sessions Lily she does one word coaching
for me I want to throw in I'm gonna talk
to her first
I haven't talked to her she's not awake
yet but I want to throw in five bonus
eyes so one with me and hopefully five
follow-up sessions with Lily afterwards
okay you guys got the rules I'm gonna
type in believe and have it ready to go
I haven't see you guys can follow along
it's happening when I type it in
whoever's after me they're gonna get it
okay we still got five more to go mm-hmm
I mean I'm on the trigger I'm on the
trigger I'm ready to go okay
answer the question taneish how do I get
in contact with people whom I admire so
it's actually a lot
easier than you'd think the the the way
that I do it is if I don't know them
period I like it's totally cold I'll
tweet them out
I'll get involved in their community
I'll try to find ways to get on their
radar
what do you point tonight your point is
something well the people who type are
spamming believe hey we're not ready yet
guys we've gotta cross two million okay
I'm I got mine on the trigger here
though I got mine ready to go so let me
run through a couple examples with you
guys so you can kind of get a sense of
how I do it
first what I wanted to get the
collaboration is in the YouTube space
the first two people that I collab with
with Tim Schmoyer and Derral Eve's and
they were much bigger than my channel at
the time they're all I think now is like
half a million and Tim is that I don't
know a couple hundred thousand four
hundred thousand maybe way bigger than
mine I had like fifty thousand subs
something like that in my path in
started with them getting to know me so
I was active on their channel if there's
anybody who is active on social before I
ever asked for anything I would try to
be active on their channel on their
Twitter feed on their YouTube channel
tight we got two more two more one more
one more guys I got I got my I lied to
that question but I'm gonna I'm gonna I
got my my fingers ready my fingers ready
Oh believe me I didn't who's after me
who was it who was it who oh my god is
going too fast
who was it who was it who as it wasn't
as I typed it in savvy fella savvy fella
email my assistance and you're out Evan
Carmichael calm and we will set up the
one-on-one coaching session with
potentially five more fallouts with Lily
you can all think Nina for waking me up
I thought I would have been up by now
but it would have been tight yeah I love
it savvy fella savvy fella is one happy
person and one hated person by lot of
people do okay but when I get in there I
wanna I wanna answer more questions
you guys I want to give him any more
bucks we got stuff to give away we fell
back down hey hey again okay okay so I'm
gonna share my story how I got in
contact of people I admire so Tim
Schwerner leaves I was active on their
YouTube channel I was leaving comments
on every video I was I wanted to be a
known quantity right I wanted to be a
known quantity so that when I did do an
outreach they knew who I was and and
there's people who are very active on my
accounts so I love all the happy faces
coming in if you notice in the chat I
saw a man who villains a know they both
they both have a little blue thing next
to them that means they're
administrators and they're administers
because they were very active on my You
Tube community they were leaving lots of
comments they were involved in the live
chats over and over and over again and
so I made them admins there's a no right
there he's a know hey say no right
there's a valet they both got shout outs
11 and there's a couple of other people
who aren't here who've been mated mins
and who are very active and if they
asked me for something then I want to
have a conversation and I've never met
either these two guys face-to-face in my
life but if they ask you for something I
would I would do my best to help them
out most of you are the guys I've never
heard of you know you're not active
enough on what I'm doing and so if you
come to me cold it's a lot harder to get
a yes than if you come to me with
already having given value first and so
that's what I would be looking at doing
as much as possible if you're trying to
target somebody who is already posting
some kind of content comment be a part
of the community being engaged with what
they're writing support them retweet
their stuff so that when you do reach
out with an ask they already know who
you are it's a lot easier so that's
that's my that's my first strategy in
terms of getting in contact with people
you admire second thing I would be
looking at is how can i form some kind
of connections to get to that person so
as an example I really wanted to have
howard schultz in my book howard is the
guy here he's he's the one who built
Starbucks
I really wanted to have him in my book
but I know him
and he wasn't on social media you know
Howard Schultz's not on social if you
look for Twitter or YouTube or any of
the channels he's not there so that's a
that's a problem right I can't use my
go-to strategies and so what I did with
him was I need to find some kind of
connection in I knew nobody who knew
Howard you know I went to LinkedIn you
know trying to find all my possible
sources and the one that ended up almost
working was he has a ghostwriter for his
book on word I love on word it's
somewhere in myself it was ghost written
with somebody and so I wrote to her the
ghostwriter and said hey I love what you
did with Howard I'm a huge frame and
just explained what I was trying to do
and she made the introduction to the
head of global PR for Starbucks and we
just couldn't make it happen in time you
know I was on a book deadline and we
couldn't get the schedules to happen in
time to sit down and do an interview
with Howard for the book I didn't want
it to be anybody else and I didn't want
the global PR had to be in my book and
wanted to be Howard or nothing so anyway
finding unique connections in J rise was
a big help here to get me off the board
with that finding some connections for
me we looked at Howard has a venture
capital fund and who helps him run that
fund and a whole bunch of other other
paths like you do your research and try
to find all sorts of different paths and
avenues in as opposed to only going the
straight path each time third thing I do
I will just blind tweet people to be
parts of my videos so when I do top tens
you may have seen some of the people
that they do their own intro so they do
a thank you message at the end we've
done that with Grant Cardone
Tom Beale you TD jakes a whole bunch of
people let meet their own messages for
the video a lot of those some people I
know and some people are just cool
tweeted and I just write to them say hey
I'm making a video on you do you want to
be a part of it
and I'll just do it to everybody it's
having it's not having to fear so I
tweeted Barack Obama for making a Barack
Obama video he didn't reply but he's
following me now so that was just saying
you know and most people won't reply to
doing that way without a connection
those people won't reply but it's also
not having a fear you know because
there's a chance that he might reply and
I don't want me to take me out of the
game right I'd rather Barack Obama takes
me out of the game but too often we take
ourselves out of the game by not even
trying we answer for that person right I
want Barack to answer for Barack not for
me they ain't for Barack and say no
right I want to give him the know
instead of me giving myself to know all
right I think too often we do that as
entrepreneurs even just as people in
general and so those are some of the
ways that that I've used to get in touch
I think the most important thing once
you are reaching out though is that they
see the hunger they see the passion they
see the drive they see a younger version
of themselves
mentors love giving back we did we love
giving back the problem is most mentees
don't do anything with the advice and so
it becomes a waste of time that's the
challenge how do I get it off this thing
there we go a lot of times mentors would
give advice and it just gets wasted
I just gets wasted nothing happens and
so I don't want to go off and do that
again and that's the biggest that's the
biggest challenge you're going up
against two competing forces one that
mentors love giving back and two mentors
hate wasting their time so you need to
prove that you're not the one who's
gonna waste their time you're gonna be
the the 1% who actually takes the advice
and does something with it and so the
way to do that is with with your message
right tell your story tell them how much
you love them tell them how much you're
really gonna appreciate them you know as
an example a girl wrote to me and said I
love what you're doing I would love to
have some of your time to answer some
questions even if it and this is the
line that got me even if it was just
walking with you on the way to your car
I'll take that meeting and I'll bring
I'll bring coffee and snacks like that
Joseph now don't don't use that on me
again okay that's not original anymore
but that got me it's like this person
really cares this person really has
hustle and drive and so I'll meet with
her I'll meet with her and see and so
showing that you have that same hustle
and drive makes it easier for them to
say yes and you may not get the yes the
first time you may have to continue to
follow up continue to follow up go to
their city like if they have an event
happening or if they're coming in your
city you go there and you meet them and
you support them so those three things
what did I say that there really is tim
schmoyer strategy of of supporting them
being engaged on their channel being
engaged with their content trying to
find ways to help out to the howard
schultz strategy of finding people who
are connected to them
and finding some kind of way in and then
three Kol tweeting them cold messaging
them if they have a social media account
and when all of them is showing your
heart your energy your passion your
drive that you really want this so
you're more likely to get a yes Tanish
great question congratulations again the
book we've given away five so far and
they gonna give away another book oh it
isn't you okay we're losing Nina by Nina
you want to say bye-bye Nina thank you
for waking me up other means I have to I
have to pick the winners next time okay
guys tag me in questions and let's go
let's keep another book okay here we go
gender Evan if you had to start all over
again what would you do differently
that's a ray Gonzales can you think and
grow rich is be okay guys time to vote
back to the chat a if you had to start
all over again what would you do
differently be can you think and grow
rich like Napoleon Hills a or B vote
vote vote vote err be a if you had to
start a live again what would you do
differently be can you think and grow
rich like the polling he'll see come on
who voted see you guys
I'm seeing a lot of A's I'm going eh hey
gender gender gets a book gender gets a
signed book Cain delivered will not hand
delivered no it won't be hand delivered
well will be but not by me
gender email my assistant Sandra at Evan
Carmichael calm we'll get you the book
okay if I just start all over again what
would I do differently so this you know
so I hate this question most of it cuz I
you know I don't think backwards I don't
I don't look backwards and think here's
what I would do differently if you put
me back when I was nineteen in my first
business I'm sure I would change a whole
bunch of things but I don't spend any
time thinking back there so my my my
real answer is I wouldn't I don't think
about it so I wouldn't go back and do
anything and I think too often
entrepreneurs and people spend time
thinking in the past living in the past
you know we're reflecting on those
mistakes and and that prevents you from
being here now and moving forward to
something better
right so I think that's a big problem if
your goal is like hey you want to learn
from my failures and what would I do
differently from that perspective the
only thing I would say is just to
believe more to believe harder too much
self-doubt not enough self-confidence I
think it's the value of figuring out you
know what your one word is right the
self-awareness at the beginning I was
too afraid to talk to people who who
were my customers because I was 19 years
old and I didn't sell I didn't know
anything about science and I barely knew
anything well sophomore and I was
telling a scientific software science
was my worst subject in school the worst
I dropped it as soon as I could
and here was selling biotech software
you know it's not a great combination
and I was afraid to talk to these people
who were - three times my age with PhDs
and it wasn't really until it just
figured out that hey all they care about
is that I can provide value and that I
don't need to get into the tech and the
specs I can give that off to my business
partners people to handle
and then over and over and over and over
and over again like every major
breakthrough I've made in my business
hasn't come from a strategy it's come
from me breaking through a limiting
personal belief it's come from me not
not not not believing myself
does that make sense if it comes to me
believing myself more every time I've
made a major breakthrough my life that's
what happened came from me believing in
myself more and so I think that's really
really really critical I would go back
and just say hey Evan that that thing
you're scared about it's nothing
you got this just do it now and I
honestly try to keep that in mind
constantly that sniffles the thing that
drives me a lot is is the idea of regret
of not living in regret and essentially
what that is is a you know however I
however old you are when you're when
you're dead or we're about to die you're
200 years old looking back on your life
and saying I regret not doing this
and usually regrets for not actually
that you took the regrets there actually
you did not take and that's essentially
what it's a conversation right is a
conversation so I'm how old now Nina how
old are mine 37 37 I'm 37 and a half 37
and a half so what would my 200 year old
self tell my 37 and a half year old self
probably believe more but also that's
that's the reality that I live like if
you if you get into that mode on a daily
basis that I don't want to let my future
self down that I don't want to live with
regret that I don't want to be afraid of
the projects I'm taking on that's I want
to be proud of what I can create and
show my grandkids that so I'm constantly
having a conversation with my 200 year
old self and that drives me forward
through the fear of whatever it is that
I need to get up and go and do thank you
for the questions in there and congrats
on the book get that off to you let's
give away another book give me your
questions tag me up what do we got let's
get to
chat Johnny where's Johnny Johnny Johnny
what's your current what's your current
plans on going to the next level and how
are you going to execute it okay and Z
oh man
flowing in zeros easy how specific do
you need to be when it comes to setting
your goals and dreams okay
those are our questions every vote vote
a vote B a is what's your current plans
and going to the next level and how are
you going to execute it
B how specific do you need to be when it
comes to setting your goals and your
dreams a or B vote a or be a or be a or
B where do we got si si B's I see B's
again a what what are my current plans
are going to the next level and how am I
going to execute it B how specific do
you need to be when it comes to setting
your goals and dreams here be a I'm
seeing a lot of A's I'm seeing I'm
seeing some B's I'm seen I'm gonna go
away we're gonna give it to Johnny 9
Johnny you just want a free book signed
by me get a mail it to your place email
my assistant Sandra at Evan chemical
calm and we'll get it off to you okay
let's answer this question what's your
current plans like going to the next
level and how are you gonna execute it
so this is this is an interesting about
me interest is an interesting thing
about me when as soon as mentally I've
hit my goal I kind of check out from
achieving it so for me my goal was hit a
million subscribers before the end of
the year and once I realized that I was
gonna do that it's like okay I got that
goal great now what's next what are we
doing next so that happened at the
beginning of the year was little slow at
the beginning of the year hitting 1
million was gonna be a stretch goals
like I might hit it I may not hit it I
have to get better to be able to hit
that we're gonna we got to improve
things to be able to hit that and so
that was that was a stretch at the
beginning but as I got into it specially
the past four or five months every
okay you know what I got it we got it we
got I have to really screw up not to get
it we have to tank the YouTube album has
to change something big has happened for
me not to get it and then it happening
you know over a month early the goal is
in of the year when we hit it in
November which is awesome but as soon as
I as soon as I in my mind have a goal
that I know that like it's achievable
and I'm about to hit it then I'm not
excited about anymore you guys are
probably similar I just it's just not
exciting anymore like okay that's done
mentally it's done so then I thought
okay what am I going to do next and and
two million is just not exciting you
know like it's not I don't know it's
great I mean I'm super grateful and
appreciative to get to two million
subscribers but it's not for me it's not
personally driving and motivating so 10
million is the next kind of big goal but
it's also super far away right how do I
get the 10 million faster how do I get
10 million faster and somewhere along
the way in that thinking I switched my
mindset to I want to I want to help
solve the world's biggest problem and I
honestly feel the world's biggest
problem is untapped human potential it's
not healthcare it's not anything else
it's untapped human potential I believe
that most people are not doing the thing
that they should be doing you know the
person who can solve cancer is is
manager McDonald's the greatest
basketball player of all time is not
Michael Jordan it's somebody's an
accountant you know I think people get
miscast and I think people don't take
enough responsibility for trying out
enough things to find the thing that
they love and so they settle for a much
less meaningful life I think just in
general most people do that so there's
that and then there's also the people
who are on the right path giving them
the confidence and motivation the tools
they keep going they have success and so
what does that look like you know
hitting going after that goal
immediately I get hit with a wave of you
know I'm not worthy to do that whoo
to do that that's it's the biggest
problem ever how can I do that and then
I start moving to the to the execution
like okay well if I want to do that then
then what are the steps
what are we need to go through who are
the people who need to partner with you
know I've been really fortunate over the
past especially the past year you know I
had a billionaire want to buy my youtube
channel I had one of the biggest guys in
Hollywood want to partner up on a movie
or a TV deal and I don't know how to use
those resources yet when he asked me
what do you want to do a movie or a TV
show I don't know I haven't thought
about that
what do you think do you want do you
want to do a TV or movie deal with me
and so you know the billionaire who
wanted to buy my channel can I pitch in
something else right can I pitch him a
different idea what is that idea and so
I I don't haven't worked out the next
the next this is a lemon wrestling with
for about a month and the website I
threw together super quick if you go to
my home page now it's just a bunch of
pictures and I made that myself and
medieval on some guys on my team I'm
trying to kind of figure out how to make
that more user friendly and and more SEO
friendly and all that but that's just my
ticket out of my head and put it on the
paper I want it I want to do something
big and it's gonna again the biggest
breakthrough there's gonna be me
believing that I can you know if I why
would I go and raise a fund to go off
and help people you know do I want to
raise a hundred million dollars and go
off and buy a bunch of companies or
invest in a bunch of companies now I
haven't figured out the execution yet
but it's coming and I know it's gonna be
that my unique talent is believing in
people that's what my unique talent is I
can't solve cancer I can't I can't do a
lot of things I have no interest in in
learning those skills you know I don't
want to be the guy who sells cancer I
want to support the girl who goes off in
solves cancer
that's what I want to do and so doesn't
mean partnering up with a whole bunch of
different people and a whole bunch of
different venues right now is focused
most on the YouTube stuff so I'm talking
to a bunch of different people who can
potentially bring a new content flavor
some new angles to my channel but I'm
starting to expand and if you look at my
website I created what I call the circle
of potential all the things that can
help you realize your potential
and in each of those areas I'm gonna be
making bets I'm gonna be making
investments and making partnerships I'm
gonna be making building businesses
whether I start to myself or a partner
with different entrepreneurs so that's
where I'm going it's not super clear and
that frustrates me and part of building
the website like I put up that website
incomplete intentionally because when I
go it bothers me and so I need to fix it
I need to make it better and I'll keep
you guys posted with the vision and some
of the ideas as I continue to go but
yeah I want to do something big and
hopefully you guys will join me for that
journey Thank You Johnny for the
question giving away another book okay
let's give another book right sign book
give me your questions pop em in tag me
in the question what do we got
Caribbean curls Caribbean curls are you
ever worried that you'll run out of
content or ideas and Enrique and any K I
need K okay how do you go through the
depression as a young entrepreneur okay
hey guys time to vote time to vote who's
gonna get the book hey are you ever
worried you'll run out of content or
ideas B how do you go through depression
as a young entrepreneur a or B vote
let's see a you ever word you're running
at content or ideas B how they go
through depression as young
entrepreneurs what do you got oh I got a
lot of bees that's the same person same
don't vote a thousand times right back
to back what do we got B or C miserable
miserable ass B - okay we're going be an
ek congratulations you just want a sign
book we're gonna get it mailed off to
you email my assistant send your a Devin
chemical calm book number eight
give it away I love it let me grab some
water okay how did it go through the
pressure as a new entrepreneur so I
think there's two things here one
depression is you know if it's really
serious if its clinical you know you
might want to see somebody about that
you might want to talk to professional I
haven't gone through like severe
depression and so if you're really at
that stage I don't want to be giving
advice on how to deal with depression if
it's like super super serious that being
said I think I think every entrepreneur
goes through some really low lows you
know we tend to focus on the highs and
the selling the business and the getting
the clients and all that stuff the
growth the vision excitement but the the
negative is real you know the downside
is real this the self-worth is real and
I remember my first business it was it
was the lowest I've ever felt about
myself it was the lowest self-esteem
lowest self-worth really just feeling
like you know I'm contributing nothing
and for someone like me who likes to
have an impact that's like the worst
thing that you can you can do to me you
know the worst day of my life was
telling a business partner that I quit
and that I didn't want to keep going and
I ended up not quitting and the next day
just got up and said I need to find a
different way to stand and that's where
the idea of maudlin success came from we
realized I know the first guy to try to
do this before how do I deal with it I
deal with it one from one remember why
I'm doing it and I think it's really not
getting so attached to the results like
ever think about how we deal with it now
when I have more strategies and more
ideas it's not not getting attached to
the results but enjoying the process I
mean if you look at anybody who's had
success and we've covered a lot of them
on this channel anyone who's had success
they had tons of failures I had lots of
down moments and if you're only addicted
to the
then it's an empty it's an empty
existence you know if I was only look at
this as an example this one millionth
subscriber live stream for weeks I put
it off coming up with ideas on how we're
gonna do this what's what's the idea
gonna be how we're gonna how we're gonna
celebrate 1 million together and I asked
Nina and asked my team gr eyes bunch of
the people I cave I need help
can you guys organize what I'm gonna do
am a million live stream and mostly
because I don't really care about the
million lives to you I know I don't care
about the celebrate I don't need the
celebrations for me personally I don't
need it like once I hit it boom I did it
I know I'm gonna hit that buy think
before they end here great move on it's
in Mexico and I want to do it for you
guys I wanted to do it to celebrate with
you guys because you guys have been a
huge part obviously of what I'm doing
but for me I didn't need it and it's
because I'm not attached to the outcome
I'm attached to the process much more
important than doing a million live
stream is what's my next video you know
what's okay so the interests of today
cuz we're doing this but like what's the
interests of today what's the top 10
that's going on today is it good is it
really good as a gonna impact some lives
is it an awesome message how do I make
those better and you see that over and
over and over again and you haven't seen
Jerry Seinfeld's top 10 rules I
recommend looking at it because he talks
about doing the torture that you can
endure to have success you need to find
the torture that you can endure that the
work that other people would find
torture but you can do it you don't find
it as torturous a lot of the work that I
do like I love the work that I do almost
all of it you always have a piece that
you don't like but I love I love the
work and I think if you're just attached
to the outcome and it doesn't work out
then it's easy to get depressed right if
you're just attached to hitting a
million subscribers and because I
million dollars or whatever it is and
then it doesn't happen then you get
depressed and you get down and and I was
there but if you can find joy in the
work joy in the work
you know the the marriage is more
important than the wedding date you find
joy in the work you love doing the work
itself then it's harder to get depressed
I think the lows don't feel as low I'm
sure you get you'll get some lows like
some opportunity comes and it doesn't
work out or you got excited for
something and it didn't happen if I
didn't hit my mailing by the end of the
year yeah I didn't get my goal I feel a
little down but nowhere near as down as
the high I'm gonna get from getting back
in and doing the work and so I think
that's really really crucial is focusing
on the journey not the destination
focusing on the marriage not the wedding
date you got to love the work that
you're doing and hopefully the work
fills you up like the work that I do if
I've had a bad day something happened
you know in life coming to the YouTube
comments or making videos makes me feel
better like the work makes me feel
better you guys a community makes me
feel better all of this makes me feel
better and if I hit my goals or not if I
sell you know I'm launching my new book
you know this it so this book you like
give it if it hits the bestseller list
or not you know they're great minor
goals are more important more important
for me then like your one word hitting
the bestseller list or my next one the
top ten rules hitting the bestseller
list is that people enjoy it like you're
reading it and it's having an impact on
your life that stop happening it makes
me feel really really good and I'm
fortunate and spoiled now that there's
so many of you guys and everybody we
make I get comments on and and it's a
really positive community but at the
beginning when I didn't have even a
YouTube channel and I was just doing
speaking engagements I would make a
PowerPoint file of some of the most
positive comments that I received for my
speaking engagements and I would watch
that every morning so it's like like 20
of my most popular or most like my most
positive comments that made me feel
excited and
every morning I would watch that just to
remind myself that the work that I do
matters that it's touching lives it's
having an impact even if it's only a few
people even though it's only 20 people
and so I think that's really critical
find enjoying your work having the work
itself lift you out of a negative state
or negative environment because you may
not have people who support you and you
doing what you're doing so you have to
love the thing you're doing so much
because it's gonna be insanely difficult
to get it off the ground so it's my
answer thank you for the question an ek
an equate Congrats and get in the book
it's time to give away another book
let's do it book number nine okay hit me
up with the questions what do we got
whoa they're coming in they're flying in
okay let's let's let's stop it here what
do we got - MA - ma I'm so proud of you
I wish you all the best I really believe
that you're gonna do more I want to know
okay I want to know what's your biggest
goal in life okay okay okay I'm saving
that a is two months I want to know what
your biggest goal in life is and then
Ray question B how would you decide
which company to invest into and is
there a specific industry that you're
looking at all right that's it a and B
vote what do you got a I want to know
what your biggest goal is in life
B how would you decide which companies
to invest into and is there a specific
industry you're looking at a or B a or V
a or b who gets the book hey I want to
know what your biggest goal in life is B
how would you decide which companies to
invest into is there specific industry
and we got vote vote vote vote I'm
seeing the mix so I'm seen it's a pretty
split mix this is pretty split mix
leaning towards B when I'm seeing some
A's I'm gonna give it to both two
winners to my NRA to my end
both get signed books email my
assistants and your I live in character
calm and we will get them up to you let
me let me fire through these my biggest
goal in life to my my biggest goal in
life is to solve the world's biggest
problem untapped human potential talked
about a little bit already it's on my
website more details coming soon but I
think it's important to just let me
extract a little bit more on that to
give more value to you I think it's
important that you have a goal that your
biggest goal in life has never
accomplished I think of Ted Turner's the
guy who started CNN and billionaire you
know his dad had a goal his dad reached
his goal and then his dad killed himself
because he hit his goal well he had
nothing else to live for and Ted wrote
in his book and that really stuck with
me that you want to have a goal that is
so big that you never accomplish it so
there's always something to strive for
and you guys I felt this probably on a
micro level just like me like I hit my
million like okay I hit that now what
every time I've hit a little goal that I
thought even was a big goal you hit it
and then you get a little sad I sold my
business like yeah we sold my business
like oh now what do I do what Wow what
do I wake up and do the next day and I
got a little almost a little depressed
didn't know what to do and so you you
guys had probably felt that same thing
when you hit a goal that you want to you
know you feel a little sad as much as
you feel happy it's a weird weird mind
twist so I think it's important to have
a big goal that you can never reach and
then you have mini goals along the way
so my goal before was hidden helping a
billion entrepreneurs I've adjusted it
to solving the world's biggest problem
untapped human potential and it's never
solvable you know like there's always
more human potential possible right
there's always more and so that's my big
goal it's something I'm gonna work
towards you know until I die and it's a
huge scary crazy goal and there's gonna
be a lot of little goals along the way
hitting 10 million subscribers will be a
goal a bunch of other ones but that
that's my biggest goal in life and
hopefully I never lose the passion Drive
and energy to make that happen
raise how would you decide which
companies to invest into is there a
specific industry you're looking at so
if you go to my website I can shed I can
show you let me show you guys let me
show you guys we were here let me show
you guys Evan Carmichael calm okay
that's the new site here okay
circle of potential but you can't see my
mouse okay that's fine
this is uh this is where I believe if we
can figure this stuff out that's when
you start to unleash your potential
it starts with self-awareness so
understanding you one word figuring out
what you stand for your values your most
important core values and then building
a life and business around it create an
action plan creating an environment like
the environment is so important guys the
people you hang around with your office
environments you know it's super
important you are a product of your your
five closest friends your product of
your environment so you want to change
and do something big you need to change
your environment the habits that you do
on a daily basis right why I wrote the
top ten rules comes December 6 December
6 alright got lots of exciting things
happening it's because I want people to
read one page a day read one page a day
of a successful entrepreneur their two
best bits of advice and and do something
like if you've read that every morning
that like I do except this morning
because I came to me with you guys it
starts to seep into your head like much
more than just reading the book front to
back reading things so that every
morning you get something injected into
you that makes you want to go off and do
something amazing it's important so your
habits matter right what you and a daily
basis matters accountability
entrepreneurs aren't accountable anybody
yes our customers but our customers
aren't really pushing us to be better
we're accountable to ourselves and so we
will let ourselves down and so building
an accountability to help us actually do
the things that we say that we want to
do and that we know what we want to do
next
mentoring being a lot of people have
done a lot more than us both in terms of
aspirational mentors at people that I
cover on on the channel the top tens and
so on
and actual like real-life mentors
one-on-one expression is an expression
of self so clothing jewelry you know
whatever like if you're if you're if
you're wearing clothes you shouldn't
need to go where a special hoodie
because you want to look cool
you don't wear clothing to try to
impress people they should be an
expression of yourself you don't need
the clothing you're expressing yourself
through the clothing it makes a big
difference and so be able to express
what it is that you stand for in all the
different aspects of your life
experiences is the last one that's going
to events that's doing unique
experiences that that take your thinking
to the next level that push you through
your comfort zones that you can do in a
condensed period of time that you may
not be able to do otherwise right out
and so this is this is what I call a
circle potential all of these except the
action plan is clickable right now
it actually plans to take a lot more
work and all of them are just temporary
placeholders it's things that I'm
working on and these are going to be the
areas where I'm investing my energy my
time my money my resources my expertise
into a logistic kicking and didn't take
any medication at this wanted so this is
we're gonna be investing and and I don't
know what it looks like again whether
I'm whether I'm just investing money
whether I am partnering up with somebody
whether I'm launching new businesses in
these areas this is what I see as being
the answer to unlock human potential and
so I'm dedicating the rest of my life
to solving that problem and investing
into these in various areas let's get
back to Oh where's the live where's the
life
this one is live there we go back to the
live and I need to load up my chat to so
I can see what's happening and we go
okay so to montre congratulations you
guys win the books are you giving away
ten so far I have fifty books to give
away guys and then 50 packs of
entrepreneur heroes trading cards when I
get them on the live chat so it'll be
afterwards in the comments but let's
keep going let's get some more
questions in tag me in a question what
do we got what do we got cool coke a
love their kid okay probably butchered
that name what is your advice to people
in the 20s who are not sure if they're
on the right career path okay I like it
and then three how to handle adversities
okay that's what we got a and b.a type
this in here B okay a what is your
career advice for people in the 20s who
are not sure if they're on the right
career path B how do you handle
adversity is vote a or B what do you
guys hey or be a or B what is your
advice a advice to people in the 20s who
are not sure their career path B how to
handle adversities let's see I see some
bees coming in I see a lot of bees see a
lot of bees I'm gonna give it to be b3
you want a book signed copy email my
assistants and you're at Evan chemical
calm we will get it off to you okay so
this question is similar to the one on
failure I see it as similar the one on
failure adversities are just gonna be
part of the game adversities are normal
adversities like you you want
adversities you don't want to win a race
against three-year-olds right if you
were to race against three-year-olds you
would win easily you could probably run
backwards and win but that's not a fun
race like you want you want to have
adversities you want to have some
competition you want to have somebody
push you to be better
got some water I think that's important
and adversities are part of the path so
I think a couple things to you a handle
adversity first thing I would do is
recognize that it's normal that is part
of the part of the journey
I'd be looking at successful but
successful people that I look up to look
at their story that's one of the things
that really helped me and my business
was just recognizing that all these
people that I looked up to that had huge
success they had tons of adversities
growing up too they had in most cases
the people that you look up to and love
and respect have it worse than you have
it right now
like they had way more adversity than
you currently have now in your life so
what are you complaining about
and that was inspired to me to look at
Oprah Winfrey who was so poor that she
had to wear potato bags like her
grandmother would take potato sacks and
and cut them up and sew them into a
dress cuz they couldn't afford to
actually get her clothes you know and
and being abused and having almost had a
kid and all of this stuff like your life
is not worse than that you don't have
more adversities than that it's crazy
and then she became a billionaire
massively successful and it's it's like
stamped repeated over and over and over
again the people have the most success
are often the ones that have the most
adversities growing up so you know it's
normal so one is normal - I would
research the stories and and look at
people that you look up to and look at
how they did it and just I think you
need that on a regular basis I don't
think like you could just read Oprah
story once and then boom you're fixed
and you won't have any adversity and
you'll be able to handle all of it as
you go through I think it's I think you
need it on a regular basis why have it's
why I made my channel is why I wrote the
book the top ten rules to be around it
consistently at least for me I need
every day you know I don't wake up every
day super pumped and excited ready to go
I mean today was awesome I'm still
waking up I'm still sniffling here but I
need it I need it every day I need the
reminder on a constant basis it's really
important for me because otherwise it's
easy to slip back down and then the
third thing I would say is just make
sure that you are doing the thing that
you love doing I think I think the
adversity is easy to overcome when you
when you love doing the work right back
to the another question we had before
when you love doing the work the
depression question then as much as you
as I keep going you just like quitting
this on an option adversities are just
gonna have to be pushed through because
you love doing this like there's no
there's no question
it's getting to that point with whatever
you're trying to do it's like breathing
like you have to do it of course of
course I'm going to do it of course
gonna push through you know there are
some things like you know are you gonna
breathe tomorrow are you gonna eat
breakfast tomorrow you're gonna wake up
the gaff of course of course we would do
that like when you get to that point
with your goal then that's when it
actually starts to shift where if you
have a lot of uncertainty and debt
within yourself like I don't know if we
can do that I don't know I might there's
a great line one of my favorite movie
lines is from Ronin Robert De Niro
movies decent great car chase scene he
says whenever there is doubt there is no
doubt right so whenever there is doubt
there is no doubt when you're doubting
yourself it's not gonna happen you know
it's a quote from Henry Ford
whether you believe you can and you
can't you're right so if you think that
you're gonna fail then you're gonna fail
and so those things I think are
important to keep in mind as I mentioned
before every time I've made a big
breakthrough my life is because I
believed in myself more that's it from
there you figure out the strategies it's
not the individual strategy it's a
decision it's the mindset it's that I'm
gonna fix this I'm gonna solve this
problem there's a lot of different ways
that you could potentially do it but
more important than the strategy to fix
it is a decision to fix it when you've
decided that you're going to fix it then
you will and until then all the
strategies that somebody may throw at
you it's not gonna work because you
haven't decided that you want to do it
yet even really decided that you want to
do it yet it's like when people look at
what tools do you use in your business
what tools what tools with tools like
the tool is not going to save you
the tool is just a tool the tool will
not save your business and there's so
many people who jump from one tool to
the next tool to the next tool to the
next tool you just constantly jumping
from tool to tool tool expecting that
now Evernote is going to save you
I have a hard time organizing my idea
Evernote is gonna save you right
Evernote will not save you the next tool
you pick will not save you
you're a decision to solve the problem
is what's gonna save you so that's what
I got thank you for the question sorry
somebody got timed out come on what's
happening here guys
Thank You Man appeal for the love let's
get to some more questions I want to
give away another book oh I saw say no
up there
Zana was asking do you already have a
topic for a third book in mind and 10
May what do we got how to start your
business during college all right let's
vote a and B a you already have a topic
for the third book in mind B how do you
start your business during college what
do you want to see what should I answer
vote who gets the book hey do you
already have a topic for a third book 10
May how do you start your business
during college I'm seeing them flying in
and seeing them flying I see them flying
in all this one's pretty even this one's
pretty even I'm seeing aids I'm seeing
bees I'm seeing morays oh I'm leaning
towards a I'm leaning towards a we're
going a hey Zuri no gets the book I
think Zeena already has a book I think
she already has a signed copy of the
book - pretty sure he does but say no
you get another signed copy of the book
if you don't already have one email
Sandra Devon chemical calm and let's do
it
do I have an idea yes actually this I
want to be my so my first book is your
one word the second book is the top ten
most of success my third book is going
to be around habits and environment so
back to the idea of the circle potential
the habits you have an environment that
you are in makes such an important
difference like if you want to learn
Japanese the best way to do it is to go
to Japan create the environment for you
or create like it's just an insanely
Japanese environment for yourself it's
it's crazy how much your environment
really triggers you to do the things
that you want to do ideal in your life
versus just keep you where you are like
your environment right now is whole
than you where you are and if you shift
your environment it makes a big
difference because thinking about things
is is difficult thinking about things
takes energy away from you like thinking
about your goals and getting yourself
motivated on a regular basis
it's hard it just is so draining and
it's easy to fall off track and so what
you want to do is be able to make it
more automatic for you so you don't have
to think about if you don't have to
think about it you're much more likely
to do it and so if you understand what
the environment is that helps trigger
awesomeness and you whatever that is
then designing that and building that so
that when you wake up and when you go to
wherever you do your work right your
home office or you're a real office or
coffee shop whatever it is that by
following your habits and by looking at
your environment you just automatically
wake up and spend your day doing
insanely productive things and most
people don't do that most people have
the opposite of that most people have
insanely unproductive days those people
have an insanely unsupportive
environment and so that's the goal
that's part of the circle of potential
right habitat environments so I might
call it like something around your
environment I think it's just super
important and that was a that was
supposed to be my second book I was
working on making that book I put it on
hold because I took on my project with
Lily so if you guys know Lily is my one
word coach she does coaching helping
people around there one word she does
speaking engagements and I'm helping her
build a million-dollar business around
her concepts and that just took time you
know it's opportunity classes trade-off
by spending time there I'm not spending
time on my book I launched the top ten
rules I never wanted to do the top ten
rules book I thought why do a book like
go watch the video is the book the
videos are better than a book would be
and I thought that for the book too I
thought it'd be a waste I thought it'd
be a waste of a book because if you just
read the whole thing like I talked about
before cover to cover
you're not getting value like you'll get
value while you're reading it and then
as soon as you stop reading it book is
done you want to apply most of the
things like so the first one is Steve
Jobs right here's ten of the best things
sieve jobs I've ever said in his life
and when I do it in this book like it's
condensed down so there's two wheels per
page you can't just blow through that
without thinking about it and that's the
most people do with the book they blow
through it and so I didn't want to write
the book because I felt like people
would just blow through it and wouldn't
get enough value from it and if I don't
feel the impact of what I'm doing if I
don't think it's gonna really help
people then I'm not gonna do it I don't
care if you throw all the money in the
world at me I'm not interested like I'm
motivated by impact and then the thing
that's flipped the thing that deflects
which thing I switched for me was the
one page per day I wanted to condense
all the rules down to rules per page and
read one page per day so you can get
through ten rules in five days so like
it's a perfect workday thing right
Monday to Friday I do it on the weekends
too but you wake up when you read one
page per day so how how would that shift
your thinking if every day you had two
rules from a super successful person and
you read one page if you did that every
morning for the next year how much would
that change you your thoughts your
habits your mindset your approach and so
before I ever recommended it to you guys
I tried it myself right like everything
that I do I it has to work for me before
I go off and do something else before I
recommend it to you the videos that I
put on my channel I liked watching
personally and so I tried it myself and
I liked it like every morning I wake up
and I get every morning I go to I wake
up I go to the bathroom if you guys
follow me on Instagram snapchat Twitter
you'll see it you don't see me go to the
bathroom but you see yeah I pick up and
read a page of the new book
and I drink a glass of water and then I
write down my goals for the day and it
makes such an impact they make such a
difference for me
and so that made me motivated to write
the second book and actually turn into a
book and not just like you know scribble
notes because it was impacting me and so
top term success became book number two
where it wasn't actually supposed to be
a book ever book number three will be
around habits and environment it's I
have a bunch of notes but it's a long
way away from from coming into
production that being said when I decide
you know when I make a decision to make
something happen then it starts to
happen so it's just a timing thing it's
gonna happen it's sitting there there's
smoke you know eventually become a big
fire I just need to dedicate time to
make it happen right it's uh it's just
not a priority at the moment but after I
get this new book out top ten rules
summer six then I don't know maybe I'll
start working on it we'll see we'll see
TDS is taking off little is taking off
so it'll see so really I come back to my
idea of the circle potential that's what
I want to solve the world's biggest
problem untapped human potential if I
look at my circle and all the points on
there is the book the highest leverage
thing for me to do that next book is
that the highest everything for me to do
to help me accomplish my goal and it
might be but it may not be so I'll have
to decide but thank you for the question
thank you for the push I'm working on it
we'll see we'll see but I'm excited my
book let's launch a book - let's launch
book - top ten rules that's number six
I'm excited by that okay let's give
another book let's give away another
book give me a question tag me what do
we got what do we got what do we got
what do we got what do we got what do we
got
Johnny 9s asked Johnny nine we ready we
here to give you a book Johnny nine give
you a book what do we got whoa it's fine
through fly-in fly-in fly-in
okay summit Havilah I see Matt Hamill
here
bills and men on the channel you got to
show him some extra life here how did
how to be a better more efficient
project manager when dealing with
different types of clients co-workers
and employees in general different
people with different ideas
okay Johnny nine weirdy did one for you
that's a good question but we're didn't
work for you good deep this intuition
power really work in business
alright here we go time to vote
who's gonna get the book and the answer
a how to be better and more efficient in
project management within with different
clients that's a be those intuition
power really work in business a or be a
had to be better more efficient project
manager with you with different clients
be does intuition power really work in
business what do you want ARB air be ARB
ARB I'm seeing some ease I'm seeing some
B's I'm going a I'm going a oh thank you
for the super chat Diane I already flew
by I appreciate the love thank you for
that love amen have L I love it we got
supported means on this channel to added
a ton of value medival you know Sandra a
David Cameron calm we'll get you a
signed copy of this book do you have
whatever eddiemetal feel like you might
have once anyway we'll get one off to
you this book number thirteen giving
away giving away 50 bucks and then 50
packs of the entrepreneur hero trading
cards okay so let's answer the question
how to be a better more efficient
project manager when dealing with
different types of clients co-workers
and employees in general I think a lot
of this a lot a lot a lot a lot of this
is is handled should be handled earlier
than what most people do and this comes
back to the self-awareness to the one
word before worrying about how to handle
these people it's attracting the right
people to work with in the first part so
one of the things that was really
interesting around the research that
didn't for your one word
was when I was talking to the different
companies so I profile companies that
went from 50,000 in revenue half a
million revenue 1 million in revenue 5
million revenue and 150 million dollars
in revenue and they'd all build their
business around there one word and I
talked to them about bringing on a team
how do you bring on the right team and
then how do you onboard them and how do
you train them and how do you how do you
work with them and almost all of them
said that they're onboarding process was
almost nothing because their recruitment
process was so good if you bring in the
people who are already of the right
mindset then you don't have to do a lot
of training or education because they're
already of the right mindset it's yes
some skills might have to be learned yes
they may have to learn how to use this
software or whatever that's fine you can
teach that but much more important is
the mindset going in is the value system
and so they spend a ton of time a ton of
effort a ton of energy filtering out the
wrong people filter out the people that
they don't want to work with customers
suppliers partners investors employees
team members all that stuff if you spend
a ton of time filtering out the wrong
people then when you bring on the people
who are good fits it's just easier to go
faster and so I think a lot of people
attack it from the wrong perspective a
lot of people talking from a skills
perspective they bring on somebody
because that person has the skills like
we need a new PHP program are great okay
who has PHP programming skills and you
end up hiring somebody but then you
don't have the same value system and it
becomes really difficult to work
together and it's a battle it's a
challenge so I think that's really
really really important I look at I look
at TDS the salsa business I invested
into and Families is is that the core of
that business and everybody has to want
to treat the students at the school like
their family it's not about teaching
dates moves is about making an impact on
that's
it's life it's about having somebody
feel welcome and like they belong every
time they're in our studio everybody
gets that and some people think that
that's stupid and that's great and they
don't they never come to us but all of
our instructors have that genuine care
and love for the students and make them
want to feel like they're part of the
family and so by being so upfront and
focused and and dedicated to that
mission then we attract the people who
want to be a part of that mission and
the people who think that it's stupid
they don't apply and they don't join and
that's better it's better for everybody
like the people who think that that
stupid go off and do something else
that's great and the people who love it
will work harder to join the team
because they love the mission so much so
I think that's really really really
important I think most people attack
from the wrong angle I think most people
talk it from just a training perspective
as opposed to the values perspective so
I think I think that's 80% of the
equation honestly I think if you're
having a really really hard time with
somebody doing with different types of
clients and you're having a lot of
issues it's not so much training that
we're talking to them it may just be
letting them go and doing a better job
with the next one of finding people who
are aligned with you and putting that
out there here's what I'm about here's
what I stand before what I don't and
you'll love me if you're like this and
you'll you'll hate me if I'm if you're
like this and it's not a judgment that
they're wrong and they're their value
system is stupid or anything else it's
just not a match for you and that's okay
that being said you know once you are if
you want look at the other 20% so 80% is
in the recruitment 20% I would just say
is in the communication over communicate
over communicate over communicate so if
you're if you are the project manager
for everything you got to deal with
different interests you're sharing the
same value system but there will still
be some misunderstandings and it's just
over communicating because the customer
doesn't understand what the programmer
understands you have different knowledge
sets
so explaining why things are happening
when you share a similar value system ex
over-communicating becomes easier right
you know nobody's out there trying to
screw you over you're not trying to take
advantage of anybody just a lot of times
and those and those managing a project
you don't you don't have full
information and you don't understand
what the other person is going through
and so being able to explain that away
makes it a lot easier so 80% is the
recruitment and the messaging to bring
on the right person in the first place
and that may mean tough decisions like
that's easy to say but that may mean you
have to let go of your entire team and
all your customers like that sucks
that's a real problem but you have to
let go they're good to go for the great
and it may be a phased process where you
bring people in over time you don't let
it let them go immediately another 20
percent it's just over communication all
right let's get more another book number
14 let's get a couple questions up what
do we got what do we got what do we got
what do we got we got Priyanka Priyanka
who's saying what motivated you to start
this okay that's a good one
and then Louise Louise what do we got I
keep it with your videos every single
morning what keeps you so motivated to
keep keep on moving and uploading your
incredible videos well it's kind of the
same question is that is that different
is that different enough what motivated
you to start this and what I guess I
said what keeps you motivated okay okay
okay I got this we got this what do you
guys want to hear we're talking
motivation what motivated me to start
this is a with Priyanka and B with Luis
what motivates me to keep going what do
you want to hear the answer to hey what
motivated me to start B what motivates
me to keep going what do you got vote
vote who gets the book who gets the
question a is motivated me to start the
B is motivating me to keep going
but do we got I'm seen I'm seen that's a
mix it's a good mix more bees I see bees
bees are flying in some a's some boats a
lot of boats I can't even go Paul
I'm gonna go both I'll answer both you
guys both get a copy of the book I was
leaning toward bees I was leaning
towards the Lewis with the bee but we
got we got a lot of both answers in so
we'll do both Priyanka and Lewis email
my assistants and whatever chemical calm
you get a signed copy of my book mailed
to your house I'm excited what do we got
here so well let's go in order Priyanka
what motivated me to start this so
what-what are we need to start helping
entrepreneurs was after I sold my
business I didn't know what I wanted to
do I joined a venture capital firm
because I wanted to raise I want the
little how to raise money he never had
the reason why me but I wanted to know
how to do it and so that was interesting
I got asked to do a bunch of speaking
and I just mentioned before I had the
YMCA gig I had three people show up and
I just I loved it so what motivated me
to start was I just didn't know what I
wanted to do with my life and I just
said yes to a bunch of stuff and I think
that's really important when you don't
know what you want to do then don't
limit yourself just say yes to the
opportunities that come your way and see
what you like I think I think too often
times we try to think our way through
things and you're not gonna find your
purpose and your passion like by sitting
on the couch thinking about it you got
to go and start doing stuff now be
willing to fail quickly move on you know
there's a bunch of stuff I tried and I
tried once and it didn't work
nothing - didn't work I just like I
didn't love it I didn't want to go back
that's the test like you try one thing
and then you see do I want to do that
again you go on a first date and you say
do I want to meet that person again
right you're not trying to get married
yet you're just thinking about do I want
to see this person again and so that's
the approach I took with with trying to
explore what I wanted to do next I sold
my business I was in a fortunate
situation where you know I didn't have
to go out and get a job
immediately I made some money for my
company but I still wanted to have an
impact and someone to feel meaningful I
wanted to provide value somehow and so I
said yes to whole bunch of things and
one of them was speaking and I just I
loved it I loved helping out other
entrepreneurs I want to go back and do
it again and I didn't know how I didn't
know if I would ever make money to know
how would ever make money but I knew I
needed to keep going and keep doing it
so that really helped me from there went
to my website from there went to my
youtube channel from there it'll go to
you know it's going to books from there
it's gonna go to virtual reality and all
this other stuff I'm sure it'll expand
and go to a bunch of different things
but the motivation was really just doing
some soul-searching if you grow up what
I want to do with my life after selling
my company and I never set out to try to
help entrepreneurs I stumbled into it
and I wanted to keep going back and I
think a lot of people just aren't given
themselves enough opportunities to find
a thing that they love you know when I
said that the best basketball player in
the world is working at Starbucks it's
because you know he or she never picked
up a basketball never tried it wasn't
wasn't part of the wasn't part of their
environment growing up and so they never
tried and they could have been the
greatest in the world but they never
tried and so their manager at Starbucks
right so I think I think if you don't
know what you want to do you need to
explore what motivates gonna keep going
I make these incredible videos thank you
for that Louise is two things one I need
it selfishly for myself I need it I need
I need the daily hit of inspiration of
wisdom of a push forward you know I you
know my in my environment I don't have
friends that push me to wanted to do
more I don't have a lot of friends who
say Evan you know your did what you did
was great but you suck like you got to
do more right like that kick forward to
say you could do more like we believe in
you and your abilities to do more I
don't have that and my solution for it
has been to make the videos because I
feel like I'm around Steve Jobs every
day
an Oprah Winfrey everyday and all these
people that I profile I'm around that
every day that gives me a daily push the
videos have been a part of my daily
habits my daily routine my daily level
up my thinking and it's had a it's had a
tremendous impact on my life personally
and you don't see it on the day-to-day
but I see it on the on the
month-to-month I see it in the
conversation with the people I see it in
people who I may not have met for a year
and then I meet them again and it's a
man you've changed like you've really
grown like you're thinking bigger you're
pushing harder where does that come from
I get that so often like where does that
come from what is that where is that how
do you get the confidence to think so
big and I don't feel like I'm thinking
big enough but for people who haven't
seen me in a while every time they come
back they've noticed a changed and so
that's that's because of the videos
that's it
I'm not out doing anything else I'm I'm
watching my own content
you know researching more videos and so
I need it I need it for me that
motivates me because I know I need it
and two is for you guys you know we have
this wonderful relationship knowing that
the work that I'm doing is meaningful to
other people's is the greatest joy of
all you know seeing the comments flying
in on every video that we put up mostly
positive and some was some of the
suggestions and feedback is great
knowing that the work that you do
matters is important and so that
motivates me every day you know when I
first started on YouTube I barely got
any comments there was a video that that
a couple months ago got its first
comment that's been around on my channel
for like five years
five years and I finally got my first
comment on it when I started I had no
comments I had no audience I was nobody
I never wanted I didn't plan to be
youtuber wasn't part of my my goals
either but you guys leave in comments
some of like the first comments came in
in coming in I did all the comments
myself in the early days and just seeing
how much of an impact it has on you as
well as the impact it has on me makes me
have to keep going
this is part of what I do so if I'm
traveling or if I'm sick or whatever
like this still video is going up we
haven't missed we've missed like I don't
fish Tina's still here
she's been added in my videos forever I
don't know we've missed like maybe maybe
like a video a year or something where
we haven't hit our timeline where we
made a mistake or something there it
just wasn't ready in time like we don't
miss we don't miss the content it's
always coming up when people are sick or
when people are traveling or people are
away your life gets in the way you know
through all sorts of different issues
you know we don't miss it's just part of
what we do and I think it's important
because I feel the burden of so much
important like responsibility you know
two people rely on the content and I
know if I wasn't you know something big
happen and I didn't I didn't produce any
videos for a week I know you guys would
be understanding and supportive but I
feel the responsibility to get the
content out in a good way it's like the
work that we're doing matters and a lot
of people count on it and I want to keep
doing it so that's why so it started off
as just exploration wanting to find
purpose and meaning in my life I think
and it continues on because I need it
for myself and I love being able to see
that the work I'm doing matters for you
guys watching thank you for the
questions Priyanka and Luis again email
my assistant Sandra Evan come on calm
and we'll get your address to be able to
send you off the books
let's get another book winner let's see
we got we've only given away 15 I got
fifty to give away I don't know if I'll
get the fifty questions and see how what
we do okay questions tag me tag me tag
me tag me and we'll get some questions
coming up okay let's go here we go what
do we got what did I click on here Dom
language D rap and your goal of helping
bring to life untapped talent potential
would you suggest a good parenting and
great teaching or what to augment your
thoughts okay okay that's one - mayor
what's the best book for entrepreneurs
all right okay those are questions a and
B what do we got a how important is good
parenting and great teaching for
untapped potential and B what's the best
book for entrepreneurs vote vote vote
vote vote vote vote who gets the book
will question answering let's see it's a
bunch of A's seen some B's seen the
mix-up bees bees please leaning towards
the be leaning towards to be got a
couple is bbbbb I'm going be be Miriam
congratulations you get a signed copy of
the book email my assistants and you're
a Devin chemical calm and we will get
that off to you what's the best book for
entrepreneurs so you know I believe my
books are the best books for
entrepreneurs I'll give you another
answer after but first off a couple
reasons one I think you have to love
your own work
III don't think about people like your
own work I don't think enough people
talk about their own work enough
it's interesting how much we'll talk
about other people's work and put our
own work down I love my books I think my
books are great I think I think your one
word is one of the most important
exercises you'll ever do in your life I
think the top ten rules to success book
that comes out December 6 is is life
changing if you did that every day if
you read one page a day you your life
will change it would just will you has
to if you're surrounding yourself with
these big thinking geniuses every day
your thinking will level up it just has
to it will okay it's automatic you don't
even have to think about it it just will
happen and so I think you need to be
more proud of the stuff that you're
creating and be willing to talk about it
and not be worried about being seen as
you know I'm not saying you guys need to
go and buy this book right now it's the
best thing ever and if you buy five I'll
do that you know like I think it's just
I think you have to be a fan of your own
work I has to come from a genuine place
that you like it and you don't you don't
you don't you don't put it down yeah
it's okay book no like I'm really proud
of the books that I wrote I think I
think they're the I think they are the
best to books or entrepreneurs only one
well you just got one
you got this one it'll be signed and the
other one I think is super important -
apart from that apart from my own
content the best book for entrepreneurs
I mean it really depends on the problem
you're going through I think the one
that helped me the most my favorite book
is the 4-hour workweek not so much the
idea of working four hours a week I
don't think that is the right thing to
do I look at Tim Ferriss he doesn't work
four hours a week but just the concept
of not doing everything yourself and the
time management really really hit me
hard I changed a lot in my in my
business and in my workflow of how I
worked on my projects and then bringing
on a team to help me so it's not just a
solo operation all the time I felt like
that book really had a big impact on me
so it's it's a bit dated now a lot of
the examples are kind of old and they
did do a revised version of it but a lot
of the principles are still good it's
just the core premise of working four
hours a week is something I don't agree
with so that's my only challenge and
recommending the book but I found a lot
of value in it so that's my answer and
congrats on the book Miriam next up
let's give away another book give me
your questions tag me Jamie let's hit
them up Jamie who is your top business
mentor and how do you start I meant to
relationship with them how did I start
with the relation okay yeah well
questions coming in Wow what do we got
what do we got what do we got holy
counts Sean Sean right here boom we got
Sean what are your thoughts on network
marketing and its incorporation of
mentorship okay so you guys get the vote
a is Jamie who is my top business mentor
and how did I start I meant to
relationship with them be Sean what are
your thoughts on network marketing and
its incorporation of my three ships so a
vote vote below who gets the book what
question am i answering a who is my top
business mentor B what are my thoughts
on network market
a or B what do you want a be a be a or b
AC some A's season is see some more A's
what else I see a B be a a a be a a P
hey Ray's here ray welcome we give you a
shout and earlier Ray's on my team ok
I'm going oh I was gonna go a but I see
some bees coming in I like how Sean goes
for himself Shawn dude Sean votes RB I
[Laughter]
love it and Jamie votes for age look at
that okay you know I'm you're both you
guys I'm gonna I'm gonna do another
double up I love how Sean and Jamie both
work for themselves that's great
okay both of you email my assistants and
you're at Emma chemical calm and we'll
get the books off to you okay who's my
top business mentor and how did I meet
them and start them into relationships
so I have a three-part answer to this
and we'll go quickly one my top mentors
are my parents they're on the wall
behind me it's a picture who decide
that's me when I was eight years old
with my parents they taught me not so
much about business but how to be a
human being
believe came from them and and I apply
that to business and so most the lessons
that I learned around how to be a good
person comes from them and then I bring
that to my company so I met them because
I was born to them the second thing I
would say most of my business mentors
they're more aspirational which means
I've never met them you know Bill Gates
was my first one that I learned from
what I've built and sold my business
because of him and now on going you know
my favorites are on the wall behind me
I've got Steve Jobs Howard Schultz AP
Giannini is my favorite entrepreneur of
all time he's he kind of cut off you can
just see his eye there on the side he
was a founder Bank of America he's the
believe banker bet on entrepreneurs when
nobody else would give out loans based
off of a handshake if you can imagine a
banker giving a loan based off of a
handshake
and a look in somebody's eye so he would
make his decisions and so uh again I've
never met him I never will a lot of
people who I study and learn from are
dead and my strategy has been much more
learn from the the greats much more than
try to go and have one-on-one
conversations and learn directly a lot
of these feet a lot of the people like
people ask me who would you want to meet
one-on-one like I don't know nobody I
don't I don't really care really want to
meet anybody one-on-one I don't really
have anything that I would ask I really
want to learn so that's why I don't do a
lot more interviews on my channel I'm
happy to do interviews when people come
but there's nobody that like I can't
wait to get on my channel do an
interview with so AP Giannini probably
the person I would want to meet if I if
I had to or if I could get a chance to
meet somebody and then in terms of
actually mentors like business mentors
that because I want to give you guys
some guidance to the best business
mentor Haag was a guy named John in my
first business runni there guys him with
John hey how did they come about I went
to a bank and I go in and say hey I'm
starting a business is my first biotech
software company and we need help
because cuz I was struggling because I'm
making 300 bucks a month because I don't
know what I'm doing because I need to
get this thing going I'm 19 years old
and I want to I want to turn down big
jobs to do this thing so I want to be a
success and the banker is like well do
you need a loan is it I don't know I
know I don't think so I don't know I
need help I I need to I need to grow my
business and you know I didn't really
realize that I didn't really know
anything right like that's not the job
of bankers and I didn't have any family
connections or anything to help me
luckily the banker I think felt a little
sorry for me and he said okay you know
what there's somebody who I want to
introduce you to who might be able to
help and he put me on to a guy named
Michael and we met with him and then he
put me on to a guy named Steve I think
and then he put me on to a guy named
John and John was the guy who ended up
really helping the business take off he
was a good mentor he gave lots of good
advice we met him on a regular basis
he helped level up our thinking make
some introductions and contacts helped
facilitate the sale of our business and
he really helped me a lot in that first
business and he came from a bank just he
came from somebody feeling sorry for me
and liking my story who went yours Ben
to somebody who'd you just miss somebody
and then I got introduced to him and I
again I knew nobody
I had no connections you know I didn't I
didn't I couldn't call on my parents and
say hey can you give me an introduction
to a mentor and it was a lot harder back
then because there was no social media
and there's no Twitter there's no
YouTube there's you know you have to you
have to go have meetings face to face to
make anything happen and it just shows
you the power of your story and your
passion that's really what got that
banker to want to think about outside of
the box ways to help us cuz he didn't
have to and we really had you know we
had no business asking for help and we
had no business with the bank right like
he doesn't wanna lend this money if we
don't even know what we're doing here's
when I lend this money to help us build
this thing off that's a less a high-risk
investment for him and so why would
somebody go out of their way to do
something nice for somebody else when
they have no benefit from it apart from
just doing a good deed it's because they
like this right by feeling like you're
helping somebody out then you're going
to you're gonna want to put in that
extra work and so I think that's showing
your passion showing your excitement can
really help get you through so hopefully
I help Jamie Sean what are your thoughts
a network marketing and its
incorporation of mentorship so network
marketing is just a business model for
people who love or hate network
marketing you should understand it's a
business model it's basically getting
you're getting customers to help sell
for you there's nothing inherently wrong
with marketing it gets a bad rap because
a lot of people do it thinking they can
just make a lot of money and so a lot of
people get in trying to get
quick a lot of people get in and just
try to sell their friends on stuff and
it doesn't work for most people because
you don't actually have a passion for
the thing you're selling if you want to
succeed you have to actually love the
product you're selling and be willing to
recommend it to your friends and to your
family right it's like you wouldn't
recommend the product or selling to your
mom
then don't recommend it to other people
most people who are getting tonight with
marketing never actually use the
products or services of selling and
that's why you're gonna fail and so if
you are actually using it and you she
love the products and you love the
company then it's great but if you don't
then you're you're unlikely to succeed
and so inherently oh there's nothing
nothing wrong with network marketing I
think you've you're gonna get into it so
one you're picking a company whose
products or services you can actually
get behind and use right just like when
I recommend something to you guys I've
used it like I recommend this book
because not just cuz I wrote it cuz I
used it right like I use the content the
top ten real success book coming out in
December I read it every day I use it in
my life right and the products and
services that I talk about I don't talk
about it that often on my channel but
when I do I use it like these are things
I think it actually help you because
I've seen it work in my business where
if I haven't seen value from when I'm
not gonna recommend something to you
guys so you have to take that approach
second thing I think mentorship is
really important I think one of the
benefits of network marketing is you
have an upline you just have to have a
good upline an upline is somebody who
recently brought you into the business
they're supposed to train you the
supposed to mentor you supposed to coach
you is supposed to guide you and they
also take a cut of everything that you
end up selling and you're the people in
need to you that you recruit as well the
ultimate success from that work
marketing comes not from you actually
selling the products or services but
comes from you recruiting people on to
help you sell your products or services
and it's the same thing in business like
the Elven the ultimate success comes
from you not if you haven't your own
company you not going out making every
sale yourself but you bringing on a team
of people to help sell for you right a
team of people to help are on the
company so that you can do higher level
things you can continue to build your
empire instead of constantly being on
the phone or being on the email
dealing with customers one-on-one every
single time and so picking the right up
line is really really important
taking somebody who is dedicated about
training and really cares and really
wants to help you improve will be there
to guide you through the process if
you're feeling I'm not doing well that
becomes a big part of why you want to
join a network marketing company so one
make sure you actually using a product
and you're passionate about it you would
recommend it to your your mom and if you
aren't sure then try it before saying
yes to a network marketing business try
the products apply it like it was a
cleaning product buy one clean your
house this doesn't work is it great is
it amazing did alene did aleene's you
know leave streaks and smell weird like
okay great don't recommend that product
and if you like the product then make
sure you're working with an upline that
will support you and train you and then
as you build your business make sure
that you are mentoring the people
underneath you and guiding them coaching
them and giving them good a bit good
advice and wisdom like just like if
you're gonna become your own
entrepreneur be a CEO of your own
business the biggest part of your job is
to mentor and train the people on your
team bring the people up underneath you
to help them do their jobs better and
grow as people so there's a lot of
parallels but hopefully I helped answer
the question congratulations Jamie Sean
you guys both got books again email
Sanjoy epic army comm she'll get them
off to you as soon as I sign them I want
to give away some more books
give me your questions tag me give me
your questions and we'll see who gets
the next one okay let's put two more
questions up next it's it's inspire
masse okay how do you remove the wall of
fear to being successful okay and a reap
how did you find your one word okay
that's it
a let's get back to the live chat there
we go
a is how to remove the wall of fear and
B how did I find my one word okay hey or
B let's go hey remove the wall of fear B
how do I find my one word what do you
guys want
vote vote vote ca's
I see an a I see a bee I see be another
be a a a that's coming in be be a your
be a is removing the wall of fear to
being successful be how did I find my
one word keep fighting keep devoting I'm
leaning towards I'm gonna give it I'm
going a I'm giving it a a inspire mass a
really great question I'm obviously a
fan talks about my book but we're gonna
give me the a inspire mass email my
assistants and you're a diamond comical
calm and we'll get you the book signed
copy okay I listen to the question how
to remove the wall of fear so I think I
think the question right away is wrong
because you won't remove the wall of
fear I think I think that mindset is
wrong I think that mindset is limiting I
think if you expect to not be afraid
then you're setting yourself up for
failure you will be afraid the wall of
fear is real the wall of fear exists and
so disrespecting it or expecting it I
think this is what happened people
expected not to be there people expect
to just be able to eliminate it and
because they can't then it's a
reflection of yourself and you think
well I'm not able I'm not good I'm I'm a
crappy entrepreneur I'll never be
successful because I'm still afraid
all these people they're off doing these
great things and they're not afraid and
now I'm afraid so I'm never gonna be
successful all those successful people
were really afraid and it's not about
removing the fear it's about pushing
through it so a better question would
happen how do you push through the wall
of fear to be successful instead of how
do you remove it and just understanding
that will help shift you understanding
that empowers you understanding that you
will never remove it we set the push
through it and so how do I do it the
best way that I know how is through
looking at my life through the lens of
regret I'm gonna talk about this earlier
on in the stream but I imagine my life
when I'm dying
200 years old or over long I'm going to
last and look back at today and say am I
going to regret this decision and most
of the time again and we regret the
things that we don't do instead of
regretting the things that we do do do
you do right most of our regrets with
our actions not taken most of your
regrets our actions not taken and so I
try to live my life imagine you're back
from h200 back to today and what I do is
that wall of fear is real that immediate
wall of fear so for me to launch a new
book might be really terrifying for me
to do my first book might be really
terrifying great that's my that's my
initial fear if I imagine my life when
I'm too hard you're looking back to
today and say look what happened with me
not writing my book decades of
unhappiness decades have regret I make
that future fear that future pain bigger
than my immediate pain so the pain and
fear of today is real the pain of
writing the book and all the self-doubt
is real but the future fear of not
writing it I just make it bigger so it's
like if you're if your nail is hurting
you know you have a hangnail or
something that's hurt it's really
bothering you got you wanna like it's
you know it's hurting you and really
itching if somebody punches you in the
arm you won't feel your nail anymore cuz
this hurts so much
that I cheat I should hurt myself doing
that and so that's what you want to do
you want to point yourself in the arm to
forget about the nail pain right so the
wall of fear is the nail the first one
and you just want to make it make a
bigger wall to help force you go in the
other direction to do the thing that
you're supposed to do that you want to
do that you really want to push through
that's what I find to be the single
biggest motivator for me
the trick is catching the fear the trick
is catching that fear when it's
happening because often what will happen
is you will just subconsciously do the
smaller thing you will subconsciously
automatically play small because you
won't
understand the fear you'll rationalize
the fear instead of saying I'm afraid to
write the book you'll say I'm not good
at write in the book I didn't you know
I'm not the best at writing I didn't do
well in school and writing I don't even
need a book who needs a book anyway like
books are so last century you know I
need a book to stand out and then you'll
you'll rationalize it away right cope
with all the reasons why you should be
doing it and you're smart so you come
with really smart reasons as to why you
shouldn't do something but the real
reason is just fear so the trick is
actually catching the fear first
catching you holding yourself back
because of fear and once you do then you
make the future for you're just so much
bigger that then you have to take
actions and the third thing I would say
is back to the environment in habits
surround yourself with people who are
facing their fears and doing big things
will be inspiring to you to want to keep
doing it yourself there's a great
collection of Clips um Will Smith that I
would recommend anything we've done a
Will Smith on the channel we'd go back
and look at again if you're afraid of
fear his his big thing is conquering
fear of fear like he doesn't want to be
afraid of anything and so anytime he
catches himself being afraid then he has
to go and tackle it so he was afraid of
jump from an airplane now he has to go
jump from an airplane and constant
whenever he's not doing something cuz
he's afraid he has to go out and tackle
it and then go out and do it and so I
think that's a good one to look at and
just in general surrounding yourself
with an environment of people who are
pushing through will give you the
confidence and the courage to push
through even though you're afraid
and again that's a success you will be
afraid it's okay it's normal fear is to
be expected and you'll never remove it
completely you just face bigger fears
thank you for the question inspire mass
and congrats again in the book let's do
another one I'm giving away 19 books
already let's go you guys are gonna
really
increase my mailing costs here number 20
okay kick me up questions tag me tag me
tag me tag me what do we got I saw
something here where was it
okay I don't know it's gone let's do it
again let's see tag me tag me get some
questions
Zen do first one
how did best divided attention between
achievement success and enjoying life
okay and front nav how did you get the
idea of VTA and believe nation all right
that's what we got you guys get the vote
the question I'm gonna answer and who
gets the book a how best to divide
attention between achievement success
and enjoying life and B how do you get
the idea of hashtag BTA and believe
nation what do you guys got a or b a how
to best divided attention between
achievement success enjoying life B how
did that get the idea for B TA and
believe nation what do you want a be
heir be heir be heir be vote vote vote
heir be who gets the book will question
my answering I'm seeing some good A's I
think we're gonna give it to we're gonna
give it to I'm giving it a Zen do thank
you for the question I love I love the
BT a in the Blue Nation question though
but we're gonna give it the a a how best
so then do email my assistant Sandra I
have a comic calm we'll get it off to
you how best to divide attention between
achieving success and enjoying life I
think just similar to like the last
question I think I think the problem is
the question I think the problem is that
you don't see you don't see them as
being coexisting I think you did you
achieve success while enjoying life
that's the question you need to answer
how do I achieve success while enjoying
life I don't see my success as coming at
the expense of me enjoying my life
that's it as soon as you see is this or
this then you lose figuring out at the
end what can you do that will help you
achieve success and you enjoy your life
in the process for me I think about
people who would love going on vacation
so like who can't wait to go in the next
vacation like I can't wait for my next
vacation I can't wait to go on my next
vacation I can't wait for the weekend I
can't wait for the weekend to come
you're constantly waited in hopes of
downtime or relaxing time or something
else coming because you're escaping a
life that you don't like because you
don't like your job because you don't
like your business because you don't
like whatever and instead of escaping a
life that you don't like I would much
rather have people move towards a life
that they want I love every day
like what day is today today's month I
love Mondays people get people get down
on Mondays where's my phone it's not
here
I hate on the snapchat filters where it
says Monday and it's like a rain cloud
over somebody's side Monday's are great
if you love what you do my knees don't
have to suck most people's live suck
most people's jobs suck and so they hate
mondays but it doesn't have to I love
Monday's I look forward to Monday's I
like Tuesdays - and I like Wednesdays as
well I also like Thursdays Fridays
Saturdays and Sundays right and so the
trick is this is your opportunity like
if you're an entrepreneur you get to
design the life that you want you get to
build the business that you want you get
to create whatever is optimal for you
and that's why a lot of these questions
around like looking at somebody's
morning routine or looking at somebody's
favorite book or whatever it's really
great to learn from and you have to then
figure out on your own what works for
you
you know if this is how Ellen must
starts a day great you could try it but
then you have to figure out does that
work for you are you gonna do the same
thing give it a try and see what changes
are you gonna have to tweak it so it
fits for you
and so like that last question about how
to remove the wall of fear the wall of
fear is never gonna be removed you just
push through it
just like this stop stop seeing these
two things of success and enjoying life
as two separate things and start asking
yourself how do I make them in and right
instead of the or this or this
find the end that's what you should be
doing go on going on that where you
enjoy the work like for me this isn't
work waking up at 5:00 in the morning to
come on in lashing with you with runny
nose and a dry throat like that's not
work I love it if you guys have been
following my my vlog series you know we
went to a cruise that's where I finish
writing my book I wanted to write my
book on the cruise
that's enjoying life for me now that may
not be enjoying life for you
great don't do that what does enjoying
life look like to you because I
guarantee you at some point you want to
have an impact for people to say like
hey enjoying life for me means lying on
the beach and sipping pina coladas you
can't do that all day long you think you
can because you hate your life and
you're stuck in a dead-end job but you
can't do that you can't do that every
day your life like you can go and travel
the world if you give you all the money
in the world
I'll go travel the world I'll go buy a
big house okay great now what do you do
because you'll get bored of that stuff
you see you won't because you haven't
done it but once you do you'll get bored
of it and at some point you want to come
back and do something meaningful and
it's a great start to thinking about a
successful life what does that look like
on your terms you know when you ask
people what balance means it's it's a
personal question
you know Dwayne Johnson the rock he
likes to wake up a couple hours before
his movie shoots to work out he has to
work out he wants to work out every
morning for like two or three hours so
he has to be on the set by 7:00 he'll
wake up at 4:00 and go work out so he
gets on the set by 7:00 and for him
that's a balance
that sounds nuts to me I don't know wake
up at 4:00 in the morning to work out
for two hours and then go at 7 a.m. to
start filming that sounds crazy it
doesn't sound balanced to me but my
opinion doesn't matter
I'm not design in his life I'm design of
my own I want to balance life for me I
think my life is balanced I think my
life is successful I think I think I'm
enjoying life I like it I love the mix
that I have right now anytime that I
don't like the mix then I have to adjust
something in my schedule I have to
adjust my calendar I gotta adjust my
priorities and that happens what what
constitutes a happy life for me right
now may not be the same thing in five
years there won't be I'll enjoy
different activities they'll have
different hobbies different interests
that I want to go off and pursue and so
changing a premise of your question to
start asking yourself how can I have a
successful business and a successful
life how can I do that if you start to
believe that it's possible and you start
asking my question then your brain will
start working towards figuring out a
solution as long as you see them as
opposites and you'll never get it your
question all right let's give away
another book we got some water let's
give away another book give me a
question where we got you get up with
two more up against each other Jayla how
do you define success what's the secret
to success okay that's one and what
Milius gnarliest what is your mindset
while approaching competitive
environments okay those are our two
questions let's go
a or be a vote have your vote guys Jayla
how do you define success what's the
secret to success be nullius nye leus
your mindset while approaching what's
your mindset while approaching
competitive environments a or b a
what's what how do i define success
what's the secret B what's my mindset
for approaching competitive environments
a or B A or B I see some bees
see an a a a B P a P P P P P P hey get
some mixes I'm gonna give it to ya it's
a mix I can't give to both will do
another both it's another time Jayla and
nily is good job email my assistant
Sandra I haven't chemical comm you got a
free autograph book coming in the mail
to you let's get to these questions okay
how do i define success what's the
secret to success i define success i
define success by being able to enjoy
the work that i'm doing every day
enjoy enjoy my day every day and that's
not always like work work i'm a business
i want to be present in being enjoying
every moment of every day that's it
that's the ideal this to shoot for it's
not always possible i don't think it's
ever possible but it's an ideal to shoot
for and so just as i'm engaged in
focused like right now i'm with you guys
you guys have all my energy I'm focused
on you I'm not checking my Instagram I'm
not I'm not doing anything else
my minds with you I want to provide
value and answer your questions
I'm thinking about my nose a little bit
but otherwise I'm with you and the same
thing when I'm when I'm with my wife I
want to be with her
it's why I don't have a cell phone
number so you can't call me nobody has a
know we has a number because I don't
have one so then when I'm with my wife
and with my wife when with my son and
with my son and when I'm in a meeting
with Alex that'll happen later on today
I'm with Alex and I'm not being
distracted by other things and I think
that you know if you're doing work that
you enjoy and you're president a moment
you know you're doing activities that
you love I think for me that success so
we just came back from Montreal for the
long weekend Dina got a new job and we
went to celebrate and we try to do a
bunch of new food for her saw some new
places Nina in Hayden's first time to
Montreal for both of them it was great
and and I did some work checked in on
some emails when I was doing that I was
doing that when I was eating world class
poutine and smoked meat sandwiches and
bagels you know I was doing that when I
was lying in Havens bed watching morning
cartoons with him as we watched How to
Train Your Dragon couple episodes you
know like I was I was just lying there
with him doing that having fun and I
think that's important I think one
picking activity that you love doing and
then to being present in the moment to
enjoy them instead of drifting off and
like while I'm with my son I'm thinking
about work and while I'm at work I'm
thinking about my wife and one with my
wife we're thinking about something else
right and you never get to actually
enjoy what you're doing so that's what I
would define success sighs gnarliest
Milius your mindset for approaching
competitive environments I like
competition I think I would Titian is
important like I said before in the
stream you don't want to race against
three-year-olds right you're gonna you
know you're always gonna win it's not
fun I want to think about playing League
of Legends
I love playing League of Legends I'm not
very good at it but I like playing if
you play against the bots you just think
it's a computer it's not fun because you
always win
if you always win it gets boring you
want to have something that pushes you
now you don't want to always lose either
that sucks but having a balance where it
feels like you're being pushed to get
better your competition makes you better
you know the New York Yankees make the
Boston Red Sox better and vice-versa now
you're your biggest enemy makes you
stronger makes you better one of the
saddest things was if you guys watch my
series on on how to get too many
subscribers I made a five or six part
series I think of of how to get to 1
million subscribers and documenting my
journey
one of the guys I looked at was Gary
Vaynerchuk and how we were we were both
on the path and I thought he was gonna
beat me I thought he was gonna pass me
and it was exciting like oh he's gonna
pass me is great like I got competition
because I don't have anybody I don't
know who I would go up against like I
don't have a friendly competitor right
now I was the big the biggest in the
space for entrepreneurs and that's ok
it's not just about being the
competition but like the competition
makes you makes you push a little bit
harder
and I got sad that that I passed Gary so
quickly and then I got excited that he
was catching up to me like Oh Gary's
gonna pass me guys Gary's gonna pass me
and then summer came when he slacked off
and okay well now I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna be carried a million so that's
fine but now he's coming back again
right like he's I think he's ahead of me
maybe daily so so we'll see like he'll
he'll he'll crosses millions soon enough
and then we might be back in a
competition and maybe not maybe I'll
just keep improving the quality and
blast off and there's nobody else ahead
and that could be that can be sad I like
having the competition to go up against
and so I see competition is good I see
competition is making you stronger
I see you know if you are just doing the
same thing over and over and over again
you're gonna lose you have to you have
to adapt you have to improve you have to
you have to keep getting better I see
people who who rip off my videos who
take videos that I do and post it to
their channel or they try to do their
own version of it but it's still like
the exact same template the same format
that I'm using like that I'm not worried
about those guys that's not my
competition those guys somebody's just
copying you they're not your competition
because you can always outdo you can
always out.you them right like I can
always if somebody's trying to copy Evan
I can always out Evan them right it's
the original I'm the original Evan and
I'm always innovating I always come up
with new things that I like where other
people who are copying can't innovate
because they're just copying and so I
think competition is a good thing I
think it's good to have a big competitor
that you you want to go up against I
think it can be a rallying call I think
it's good to have somebody on your heels
forcing you to kind of improve and get
better
I've always enjoyed it I hate I hate
just Auto winning all the time I want to
feel like I earned the victories that I
earned I don't like feeling like things
were handed to me or things were super
easy even when I started my business the
first one you know I told I told the
story but going to the banker and
looking for connections trying to find a
mentor but you know I didn't I didn't
even ask my parents for help I didn't
want my parents help they may have known
somebody that could
help me I didn't want it I don't want
anything handed to me I wanna I want to
go and earn everything that I have right
I like even if it's even if it slows
down my path you know I like feeling
like I've I've earned it and that comes
from competing competing and losing and
then competing and losing some oi they
competed eventually get in a small way
and the competing getting bigger and
bigger bigger wins taking support so
that's my approach I'm not really
competing to try to destroy anybody I
want to win but it's not I want to win
not at somebody else like losing really
badly right so if you look at me and
Gary I don't want him to lose I just
want to win right there's a difference
I'm not doing anything to try to
sabotage him I'm not wishing any ill
feelings towards him I opposite like I
want him to do better I want to have the
competition promoting him on my channel
I want him to rise up and be better and
I want to do even better the strong of
my competition gets a stronger I get and
the better for everybody like my
ultimate goal on top potential the more
quality content is out there the better
it is for everybody to win great
questions guys let's give them another
book how many should I give away on the
stream I'm gonna give away a hundred
total but I'm gonna live on the stream
we've been going for two and a half
hours have you eaten anything yet okay
let's get to some of the questions
questions tag me tag me tag me tag me
let's see what we got okay okay okay see
this thing's flying in let's go here we
go I'm positive AJ how can you ensure
your ideas are original especially when
it feels all the ideas have been taken
and how do you get over procrastination
alright those are our two a so I'm AJ
how can you ensure your ideas are
original be tidy get over
procrastination from user three to five
one and your B vote vote who gets the
book what question my answering a how
can you ensure your
original when all the ideas are taken be
how can you get over procrastination ARP
ARP a or B oh I think this is a B B
looks B yeah okay giving it to be that
one was a pretty quick clear winner user
three to five one email my assistants
and your ah Atma chemical calm will get
your address and send you a free copy
signed of my book
procrastination we've kind of touched on
this a little bit I think it comes down
to a couple things I think it comes down
to one having a goal that is inspiring
and motivating I think that's really
important I think you have to feel like
the work you're doing means something
matters is important is inspiring if
it's not you're not gonna want it to
work I don't think this is I don't think
there's such thing as a lazy person I
think you've just called yourself that
and you've had time to even the laziest
person has had times where they've
really moved where they've gotten stuff
done where they felt motivated so it's
in all of us to be able to have
motivation and drive and energy and
effort and hustle doesn't automatically
mean it's gonna happen but it is within
all of us and so it starts with having
goals that are inspiring that are
meaningful that push you you know for me
I talked about wanted to solve the
world's biggest problem untapped human
potential it's what I want to do every
day and even just talking about it gets
me excited you want to wake up and feel
like the work you're doing is exciting
alright so I think that's where it
starts to I would come back to your
environments and your habits and your
routine again I don't wake up every day
super pumped motivated excited ready to
go off and do amazing things I need to
have a routine assessment yet for
success and so I've experienced it with
a bunch of things over the years and
will continue to experiment and it's
really for you the same thing think
about the time where you felt just on
fire well you felt bold confident
courageous able to move mountains
unstoppable you've had those moments
that may not be right now if you're
asking this question but you've had
those moments think about what led to
that what let's say you feeling that
unstoppable Ness were you watching a
video were you reading the book were you
having a conversation did you go to an
event did you have a meeting with
somebody like what what leads to you
feeling unstoppable and when you can
understand that about yourself then you
bring that into your morning routine so
you make that a daily thing instead of
just a random thing that happens
occasionally so I figured out this is
this is a this is a really big deal for
me when I really figured out cuz model
and success worked for me right I'm
model Bill Gates myself for a company
built up whatever I didn't know what to
do a mild success but it wasn't
consistent I was only modeling specific
strategies so Bill Gates did this I'm
going to try this I'm gonna apply it and
it's gonna work and it and it did work
what I wasn't modelling was something
even more important which was the
mindsets and the belief systems and when
I started modeling on a consistent basis
so it's not only modeling when I had a
problem but just modeling just to be
around them madlyn just to be in that
environment that's when I really started
to level up my game and level up my
thinking and so when I the story that I
tell around this was I was meeting a
woman at a coffee shop and I used to
always worry that I wasn't going to
provide I wasn't able to provide value
to people and so I would secretly hope
that people would cancel on me even
though that this was the biggest thing
that I got most the most joy
satisfaction from helping entrepreneurs
was what I loved and yet I was afraid to
do it and always secretly hoped that the
people would cancel on me I remember
this one woman who was a pure startup
pure startup brand names I was afraid to
meet her for coffee and I was checking
my email to see if you cancel and kind
of praying she would cancel and then I
went to the coffee shop when I showed up
cuz she didn't cancel on me and and it
was a great meeting just fantastic a
beautiful soul helped her a lot I got
inspired from it too and I member going
back to my car sitting in the car
just having his moment feeling like this
is such a great moment with her I feel
so good I feel like I really helped her
I really contributed and I wanted to
cancel really like I was hoping she
would cancel on me I was hoping that
this wouldn't happen I would have lost
this amazing moment and I realized
something had to change like I had to
get rid of that belief system that I
can't provide value that I want people
to cancel on me and so that's when I
started to model I started the beep I
started to go more regular with the mall
and success by watching videos and
looking at interviews this is before I
ever had my top ten rules and all that
stuff I wanted to make it more
consistent and the more that I watched
these videos of successful people doing
big things the more that that mindset
seeped into me to make me believe that I
could do big things to the point where
now I'm talking to billionaire investors
and big Hollywood executives and people
wanted to buy my channel and people want
to do big brand deals and going
one-on-one with CEOs of huge companies
and it's all because I started hanging
around hanging around you know Steve
Jobs and Bill Gates and Oprah Winfrey
and all these all these super successful
people from the videos I went from a guy
who was afraid to meet a start-up
entrepreneur at a coffee shop to be able
to handle the phone calls with
billionaire investors Hollywood execs
and huge CEOs where those calls are
there are nothing like it's easy to get
on the call and have a chat because I
hang around with Steve Jobs and Bill
Gates in a point for every day and so
that environment really matters so I
think if you're looking at get into a
procrastination it's one having those
goals that motivate you inspire you push
you make you feel like you're doing
something important and meaningful with
your life as well as to being around
people in an environment that pushes you
to want to be better so that you can
just wake up and it automatically starts
happening as opposed to you having to
think about it and from someone like me
I don't have again I don't
people who push me I don't I don't have
a great environment that you know
friends push me to want to do more I
made my own environment I started this
channel I watched videos I read books
and that helps me get over my
procrastination I think if you wake up
every day you don't know what you're
doing you have no goals and you copy
environment everybody's gonna
procrastinate
everybody's gonna hit the snooze button
everybody's gonna want to hate their
life but if you wake up every day and
you have a goals you shouldn't towards
and you remind yourself of and you have
a good morning routine and environment
built for yourself then you can't
procrastinate like it's not an option
you just you just want to get up and go
do something and so again we've all had
those moments of feeling unstoppable and
bold and we've all had moments of
feeling lethargic and down on life and
so I don't think that that's inherent in
two people that I'm just a lazy person
or I'm just a hardworking person I think
you you build that up and anybody can
easily get to that point so that they
are taking action massive action every
day and that's one of the challenges
that's one of the problems I'm trying to
unlock because I want to see you do
amazing things
thank you for the question I love it
user three two five one getting over
procrastination let's give out another
book let's get some more questions
coming in tag me let's get some
questions and I'll give away another
signed copy of my book to the winner
okay let's go what do we got sherry Evan
what should you not do when starting
becoming an entrepreneur okay nice next
Raven can you give advice for real life
networking for introverts okay this is
some two new ones I like it okay you
guys get the vote who gets the book what
question my answering a sherry what
should you not do and starting to become
an entrepreneur be Raven can you give
some advice for real life and that
working for introverts vote a or b a
what not to do when starting the
business
networking advice for introverts what do
you want what do you want
ARB who gets the book ok got some ace
got some bees got some boats got some
boats a b b:a a b both got a good mix
okay I'm gonna go both we're gonna go
both we're gonna do both that's gonna be
25 books giving away already holy cow we
are giving away the books great
questions guys okay sherry raven email
my assistant Sandra at Evan chemical
calm we will get the books off to you
once I signed them signed copy delivered
to your house I love it okay sherry what
should you not do in certainly when
starting to become an entrepreneur I
think it biggest mistake people make
early on in business is they pick the
wrong business honestly I think people
just get into the wrong business they
get into a business cuz they think it's
gonna make them a lot of money they
opened up a book or magazine and said
this is the hottest company to start or
they watch a YouTube video and so they
started that's not the reason this sort
of business you have to have a love for
what you're doing like the most
consistent message across all the people
that I profiled is just a love for what
they're doing the people at the top of
the game love the work they love what
they do across anything again athletics
musicians entrepreneurs they love they
love they love what they do you have to
love what you do and most entrepreneurs
who start a company I would say most
people don't love what they do at the
beginning I think they just see an
opportunity and they try to get going in
the company and it doesn't work and
you're always gonna be beaten by the
person who loves what they do like if
you try to make youtube videos because
you think YouTube was a hot opportunity
right now you're gonna get crushed like
people who love what they do
like I love making YouTube videos I love
this channel I love you guys the people
who love what they do will always win
and so I think that's the most important
thing when you're starting a company
picking the right business pick anything
that you love doing a couple other bits
I would say don't spend money until you
make your money it's so easy to spend
money it's so easy to think that
problem that you have is resources where
it's never resources is always your
resource Aliss there's always gonna be a
lack of resources always always always
always always always always stop blaming
it it's gonna happen keep going stop
trying to find ways to spend money
anybody can spend money if I gave you a
million dollars you can spend it a
million different ways money it's not
the problem go often trying to find a
ways to make money that's the problem
that's what you want to try to solve for
and so I think that's really really
important whether you're certain with
the service based business whether
you're starting by getting pre-orders
from customers don't spend money until
you're making money even when I started
this YouTube channel I already have a
successful business sold and they had
this Nestle business on my website I
didn't spend any money I didn't go often
and buy a new camera and lighting and
microphone in camera main editor and all
this stuff because what happens too
often is you spent all that money and
then you don't do anything with it right
you make two YouTube videos and then
that wasn't really for me and then
you're stuck with thousands of dollars
worth of gear and equipment that just
sit in your basement and that's not
where you want to be so start looking
for ways to make money instead of ways
to spend money don't spend until you
earn so first one was make sure you pick
the right business second was don't
spend today earn let me give you a third
one what not to do I would say don't
jump into bed with the wrong partner I
think we talked about this earlier with
myth ovals question if you have the
wrong person on board
it just really derails your company and
too often you have people who you bring
on who just look really good on paper
but when you actually start working
together it's not a good cultural fit so
just because they're good at sales and
you're good at making something doesn't
mean you should be business partners
make sure that you share the same values
date before you get married
work on a small project together and see
if you like each other you don't figure
out you're one word and see if there's
alignment there understand your most
important core value and see if they
share it or something similar to you
huge problem too many people just jump
into bed with the wrong person and you
end up getting screwed over you end up
with the wrong business partner and that
really hurts and it's hard to get out of
the business once you have a really crap
business partner okay sherry thank you
for the question
Congrats on the book coming your way
Raven can you give some advice to
real-life networking for introverts so
this is a really interesting topic and
if you guys know of the channel charisma
in command there chatting with a million
subscribers talking about charisma and
he did a video on me recently about how
to network as an introvert I I don't
consider myself a natural networker I
don't talk to people next to me on an
airplane I don't try to force
conversations I don't enjoy it I don't
enjoy it my business depended on that on
sales salesmanship and that kind of
stuff I would fail I think you've got to
find the way that you could be authentic
to what feels right for you
and it doesn't mean just because I'm not
good at doesn't mean I can't get good at
it it's more do I want to get good at it
does it feel right for me to get good at
this skill versus another skill my
strategy for networking is one whenever
I go to an event
wherever I go out you know I wear
something branded I wear something that
is unique to me so I'll wear my hoodie
or wear the belief shirt when I was in
Montreal we got stopped you'll see it on
the vlog coming up and you know he
called me Michael instead of Evan
happens all the time
but I got soccer those wearing the
hoodie and people recognized me and
increase the conversation so I try to
create opportunities for people to come
and talk to me instead of me going out
and talking to them and so it's having
something noticeable that people will
want to talk to you about so for me I
have a bit of a brand and so I built
that up that lots of people watch my
youtube channel if I'm going to an
industry event people are likely to to
know me or know of me and so that's
that's a strategic part of what I'm
doing so I'll go to the middle of the
busiest room and sit down and then start
doing work start doing busy work not
busy work like just pretending like I'm
on the phone all if you start doing work
are getting on Instagram and responding
people are getting on Twitter and
responding people making videos snapchat
responding people making videos one it
makes you seem like you're busy like
you're important like you're doing work
which which let me keep it want to talk
to you and to it increases your own your
own state of confidence there's nothing
worse than kind of sitting at the
sitting on the side and like your phone
way back here feeling like a loser by
yourself versus if I'm responding to
somebody I get more energy right it's
like there's somebody asks asking me a
question I'm responding to that I'm
gonna give more energy and that energy
vibrates out right and people want to be
a part of it and so one is looking for
what can I have that would attract
attention attract interest whether you
have a brand that people may know
whether it's you know whether it's right
wearing a crazy wig or some amazing
shoes or something that is noticeable
that people want to talk about to
sitting in the middle of the busy room
not on the side and then creating some
content and and feeling and doing
something that gets you feeling amazing
and so if you don't have an audience you
know like what I'm doing Instagram or
responding people you can look at other
people's content and respond you can go
to Twitter and make a video on a certain
topic respond to somebody else even if
nobody's right into you in the first
place
so that you're gaining your confidence
and energy and a high so people want to
come and say oh who's that guy who's
that guy there I want to talk to him
he's interesting and then the third
thing I would say that really really
really helps is being a really good
listener and trying to facilitate
introductions this is something that I
was doing naturally that I didn't even
recognize as a strategy until Chris
McMahon pointed it out he said that I
seem to know everybody in the room and I
seem to always want to try to make
connections to introduce people to each
other and I was thinking you think I
knew everybody in the room and I was
trying to make introductions okay that's
interesting but when I met anybody
whenever new anybody came and introduced
ourselves to me I never went up to
anybody and said hey I'm Evan who are
you everybody came up to me not because
I'm better or have a huge ego or
anything just I'm shy and introverted so
I don't go up and say hi to people
but I enjoy the conversations so anybody
who came up and talked to me I always
asked him who they were like who are you
what do you try to accomplish like what
are some of your goals and then as soon
as I met somebody else there who had a
complimentary goal then I introduced
them so as an example is that climber
con in LA which is an event for
youtubers with a hundred thousand plus
subscribers and I never go to industry
events but this was a one that I wanted
to try out and I met Sean the guys from
video influencers and he was looking to
do videos with interesting youtubers to
get their perspective okay anytime I met
an interesting youtuber say hey do you
know Sean you want to get some exposure
for your channel let's make some
introductions and I funneled them like
ten different youtubers to do interviews
of for the channel when I met with
Charlie from charisma command you talked
about right in the book you talked about
doing a pilot for a TV show of attention
for his thing so I facilitate an
introduction to my book agent there was
a session that was happening around
getting a movie deal off of your off of
your YouTube channel so I introduced him
to those guys and so I was just always
trying to find ways to help people out I
think that's part of what networking is
about not even about how you can help me
but how I can help introduce you to
somebody else and you get remembered as
being that person that facilitates that
introduction so I think those two things
really helped one having something that
people want to talk to you about whether
you have a brand that you people can
identify with whether you're wearing
some crazy shoes or hat or jacket or
something that makes people want to be
interested in to you whether you're
speaking at the event like that's what
that would be my go-to always I never
attends it at tindy I speak I attend as
a speaker so that people want to talk to
me afterwards after they saw my my
speech to was what was number two two
was being the middle of the busy room
and start making videos and start doing
some some work that gets you animated
and excited don't be off in the corner
reading some book and feeling sorry for
yourself and then three try to help
everybody that you meet try to find some
way to be able to help them
value to their life makes a big
difference I'm certainly losing my voice
can we give away some our books you guys
want to keep going give away some more
books we're at 25 books giving away at
some point I need to eat some food guys
we're almost three hours in on this live
stream
I see the questions coming in I want to
I want to be able to provide the value
questions are pouring in so let's let's
keep it going what do we got
let's see am I not pretty here okay what
would you change about the YouTube
platform and why okay that's interesting
and next one more dota apex if we have
to choose is the better to do what we
love or love what we do okay those are
our to vote a or B what would you change
so a what would you change it with a
YouTube platform and why B if you had to
choose is it better to do what you love
or love what you do and why a or B A or
B a or be a or B when we got to see a
bunch of bees coming in bunch of bees
bunch of bees bees be awesome a's some
a's some bach the bees bees bee
is some A's
both I'm not pretty same both I'll you
know what I'm gonna give it both just
because I love that monopoly ass a and
he's saying both I love the cheering on
your competition as well
I'm gonna go both I'm gonna go both just
for the competitive spirit there I love
that so we're gonna do both guys I'm
gonna pretty dota email Sandra and Evan
Carmichael comm will get you signed
copies of my book delivered to your
house one of these ones right here to
you okay let's answer the questions
first one what would I change about the
YouTube platform and why I think the
biggest beef I have with the YouTube
platform is being able to make video
replies to comments one of the things I
love doing is being able to reply to
people with video as a comment so you
Twitter allows it snapchat allows that
Instagram allows it so if somebody
tweets me I'll often just make a reply
on video get my phone press record make
a video reply I'll often do that while
I'm working out so I have I'm working
out a couple times a week usually on the
bike and I'll just get on social and
start responding to people's questions
but also if I'm bored or if I'm standing
in line or I have a few extra minutes I
like Chris making video responses doing
him last night
you know gearing up for this today
YouTube was a video platform and you
can't make video responses the the hack
that I was using before was making an
unlisted video especially recorded and
then saving that link and then sending
to that person but one it's a lot of
extra work for the Creator to make the
unlisted video and to a lot of the
YouTube comments people don't get
notified it's crazy how a lot of the if
you respond to someone who's comment
even if you're the creator of the
channel they don't see the notifications
they have it turned off but it goes to
their spam where if you send somebody a
tweet and you tag they were nice for
your message and you tagged them they're
much more likely to see it so that sucks
to feel like hey I did all this extra
work to make this unlisted video
especially for you and
then people don't even see the video and
I just think as a as a video first
platform like that's the place that you
go to and I think about video I think
YouTube the fact that you can't make
video replies and that you can't notify
people really well of a response I feel
that needs to be improved that's what I
would do anything else what else about
YouTube that what was the question that
I would change it with the platform I
think it's a pretty great platform I
mean for all the people complain about
the algorithm and monetization and blah
blah blah I mean I think net it's a
fantastic community and a fantastic
platform all right all you guys which
I'm very grateful for so I think that
would be I think my biggest thing I
think some maybe some better analytics a
lot of the detailed analytics is two
days old you get some live stuff but the
analytics is two days old where you
think it's like this is Google this is
this is a data driven company the fact
that the analytics is two days old
doesn't let you make great decisions and
for live streams the comments are lost
all of these great comments that's why I
put them here on the sidebar so we can
keep them but in general all the
comments are lost on the live stream
after it's gone where there should be
some way that all these great comments
get to last and live forever so that
would be my suggestions for YouTube dota
apex if you had to choose is better to
to do what we love or love what we do
okay that's too early for me this
question to do what we love is it better
to do what we love or love what we do
and you're saying that they're not the
same see I just default of being that's
the same thing
do i what so if I love helping
entrepreneurs don't want to do what I
love and helping entrepreneurs or love
what I do which is helping entrepreneurs
I think I'm missing the point of this
question maybe I need some food in me
say no saying it I always pick pick to
do what you love I think you got to do
what you love but is that not the same
as loving what you do can you do what
you love without loving what you do can
you do what you
without loving what you do I come back
to know I don't know these are the
questions I don't I spend like zero time
thinking about find the thing that you
love to do and then go do that that's
what's important
that's what matters you okay yeah I'm
still doing it did you go back to bed
you know went back to sleep she's awake
again these questions about like what's
your biggest regret or the advice that
you give or what would you fix about
your past or or this kind of stuff I
spend honestly like zero time thinking
about it it's like what am i doing today
how am i pushing forward how am I
getting my mission happening that's what
I think is really important so people
like the questions so hopefully I've
answered it in listen you got a free
book signed by me coming to you let's
give away some more books
give me some questions tag me in the
chat let's go let's go let's go let's go
okay first we got James Rick what are
some tips to make sure you won't miss a
day of work okay Winston do you think
becoming rich means becoming successful
what would you choose between the two
okay here we go
amb a tips to make sure you won't miss a
day of work be does rich become does
rich means success what do you think a
or B what do you want to hear a tips to
make sure you don't miss the day of work
B do I think that rich means becoming
successful what do you guys want to see
err be here be here be here be here be
here B you got something we got an
either Diane come on Diane neither what
is that Diane it's Monday morning let's
show some love air B hey you got some
ace gets amazed B be a both be Diane
Diane come back and vote for one I want
Diane to vote for one B a a I like both
be a both a both we're getting both
alright I'm gonna give it to
Dyanne phone and i loved i am alright i
gave the boat we got both thank you
diane you made my morning alright we're
gonna do both we're gonna do both since
we got some good boats and a's and b's
guys email and sandra don't even mean
wow do not even me don't email me email
sandra at emma comical calm we'll get
you these signed books let me go through
both of these questions quick listen I'm
gonna get some value on this Diane
you're gonna like this one yeah I think
you're gonna like this one okay tips to
make sure you don't miss a day at work a
couple of things one obviously I think
taking carrier your health is important
I used to get sick all the time and
begin in the last year beginner this
year Enid this year I started the wim
HOF method was ice baths and cold
showers and breathing and I still get
allergies but I haven't gotten sick I've
been sick once all year long which for
me is crazy that's crazy good I used to
get sick just constantly and if somebody
was sick like don't show up don't come
near me I'm gonna get sick and so that
just really really really made a huge
difference in my life so I'd highly
recommend checking that out we have a
video on that the wim HOF method that
you might want to go visit I think you
could really help you but I think to
more important than that is just just
deciding I'm not going to miss a day at
work like yes your health and your
energy is really important but but so
what like if your health is down then
what like I've made videos being really
sick I've made videos being away on
vacation I made videos you just decide
that you're gonna you're gonna do your
work you know that's it you just decide
you just decide that you're not gonna
miss a day of work and then you don't
you know you look at if I look at TDS
and teaching are my teachers alms almost
always teach like the Aleks is taught
through a broken toe you know we've had
people teach through crazy situations
you know snowstorms sicknesses now you
know if somebody wants to stay home they
need to great it's more that they want
to like Alex you crazy I'm gonna go
teach you just broke your you broke your
tour he broke his foot like yeah yeah
that's okay I want to teach on it's just
like
an option it's not an option not to miss
it's not an option to miss sorry it's
not an option to miss they just want to
keep going they want to do it and so
it's just starts with you deciding I
decide it's a great example I decided at
the beginning this year that he didn't
want to get sick again I was not gonna
get sick again I just decided and once
you decide there's a bunch of different
strategies that you can then go research
like I decide I'm gonna start the
business great now what are you gonna do
about it I decide I'm not gonna get sick
great now what are you gonna do about it
once you make a decision things start to
happen if you're just looking at
strategies but you haven't decided
nothing happens and so I made that a
priority and since I haven't really
gotten sick so let's work that well
Winston was do you think becoming rich
means becoming successful what would you
choose between the two I think I think I
kinda answered this before I think
everybody has their own definition of
what success looks like and you seem to
find what that is for you that's it you
got it I mean I told you what my
definition was before and it's okay to
look at somebody else's definition but
ultimately you have to figure out what
it is for you ah the reason why I
profile all sorts of different people on
my channel if I look at the book example
like the top ten rules for success right
coming out in December we have people in
there who are successful entrepreneurs
we have Steve Jobs and Warren Buffett
and Bill Gates we have we have actors we
have actresses we have athletes we have
spiritual leaders you know we have
Satguru who and the Dalai Lama and the
reason why I wanted to put all those
people in were they all have different
perspectives on what success looks like
the Dalai Lama I consider to be
successful but he's not
he doesn't talk about success in terms
of money and so I think it's just
important that you figure out what your
definition is it doesn't matter what
mine is matters what yours is and I
would again instead of instead of always
picking these or questions like you guys
you screw yourself over with these or
questions it's always the end combine
them it's not success and like happiness
or money like bow
both both answer the both stop trying to
put things apart from each other the
answer is gonna be by combining them
together so what is what is rich and
success look like to you
what's that balance and then go and do
that that's it
next question hit me up
give me some ads tag me let's see what
you got buh buh buh okay here we go oh
ah cool
would you hire a person delivers
high-end quality work with personal
flaws to hire someone that is less
talented but works harder okay versus
what do we got we got
no heat no heat is asking I cop it in
twice following something we love but
chances of making it is very slim but
life is one time change the stability
versus enjoyments your thoughts okay so
a is higher person delivers high-end
work but has personal flaws or B follow
something that you love which has a low
chance of success but you love doing it
what are my thoughts a or B a or be a or
B what do you guys want to hear a should
I hire somebody who delivers high-end
work but has personal flaws or B do
something that you love but your chances
of making it a really slim what you guys
want to hear a or be a or b vote vote a
bee bee bee bee bunch of bees coming in
Diane's voting a bee Kaneesha
be lots of bees B be alright I'm giving
to the B sorry Diane sorry at Google
we're going B Rho heat email my
assistant Sandra at Evan Carmichael com
we'll get you one of these books signed
by me delivered to your person mailing
address let's do it following something
that we love but chances of making it is
very slim but life is one time change
disability versus enjoying with your
thoughts so the chances of making it are
slim everywhere and the chances of being
a huge success if you really love what
you're doing that's like that's your
ticket in every industry is competitive
every industry is competitive every
industry is competitive for the amount
of dollars that are available every
industry is competitive and there's
always room for quality at the top
there's always for those of you this
question we back about like I feel like
every idea is taken there's always room
for you to provide a unique end goal to
be yourself to bring what only you can
bring and to provide value at the top
always like every industry you think you
think that a market is saturated there's
always space you look at YouTube you
think YouTube might be might be
saturated there's tons of opportunities
in YouTube right now tons you can win
you can still win when I was into it it
was still super busy and I didn't know
what I was doing and I built it up I
found my own my own angle my own model
and it's working you guys can do the
same thing take whatever industry it is
that you want to get good at the key
though is that you're actually making
something that's good right that's a
challenge like can you make something
that people care about can you make
something of value of substance because
most people they don't most people look
for a quick buck and doesn't work so
they bail and move on to something else
that's the most people do well my room
was going off gonna close the door
that's what most people do and so if you
look at the people who had success they
absolutely love what they do
and they keep pushing we just did a
video at just coming out of Lee Daniels
I haven't heard of him before but he's a
Hollywood director producer big guy in
Hollywood and his advice was to somebody
who wanted to join to become a film in
the film industry and his advice was run
go the other way don't do it unless you
just absolutely love doing it and you
have to it's like breathing you have to
do it otherwise run that's the advice in
any industry any industry if you don't
love doing it run it's just too
difficult being an entrepreneur it's
just too difficult it's too hard unless
you love doing it to get great at
anything requires an insane amount of
effort love time patience perseverance
that's just insane but you just have to
keep going because doesn't feel like
work it just feels like something that
you love doing that's the key and so big
decisions have to be made with the heart
and the spawns with the head period stop
trying to make big decisions in your
life with your head that's what you're
trying to do like the chance of this
making it a success are slim so I'm not
going to do it that's a big decision you
don't make that with your head you
figure out what you want to do with your
heart and then you use your head to
figure out how this question should be I
love doing this I love doing YouTube I
love singing I love whatever and then
you use your head to figure out how to
go and execute how do I go off and do
this that's my answer
I love it guys this has been a ton of
fun I think I'm going to call it there I
think I need to get some food it's been
three hours of live streaming with you
we gave away 30 books I've got another
20 to give away and I've got 50 packs of
entrepreneur hero trading cards that
looked like this these are the
entrepreneur trading cards I want to
give these away to you what I'm gonna do
how I'm gonna give them away are the
first 20 comments on this video once it
goes to my youtube channel not the live
comments the the whatever the after live
comments the comments that stick around
and live forever the first 20 comments
on this video will get a free signed
copy of my book mailed to your house and
then the next 50 comments will get a
free entrepreneur owes trading card pack
mailed to your house so the first 70
comments on the video once it's finished
once this process once it's live on
YouTube will get prizes so YouTube's
usually takes this is a three-hour video
so YouTube will probably take I don't
know 15 20 minutes or so to process it
so keep an eye on it but when it goes
live those first 70 well win prizes
hopefully it's one of you again I just
want to say thank you for all the love
all the energy you guys helped keep me
going it's been a blast I'm glad that I
was able to celebrate live with you it's
across 2 million that means a lot to me
and hopefully you'll continue on my
journey to help me solve the world's
biggest problem untapped human potential
and as we shoot for the next YouTube
goal of 10 million subscribers let's
make it happen together guys is Monday
it's time to start the week off strong I
really appreciate all your love and
support I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever here one word is much love guys
I'll see you soon